pulled up to calabasas ready for where i
might turn to a savage i just showed up
with the crewy the baddest you just
showed up like you might need some
practice
you going down for the count it's going
down tonight i do it all for my family
you do it all for the likes i hit that
bell and i'm ready to fight turn me up
turn me up turn me up they want the belt
they don't work and know don't mess
around and i'm hurting them i say the
wrong thing we're live with the boys
welcome to calabasas fight campaign for
ufc london and i brought in a couple
fighter
experts enthusiasts hey enthusiasts
all i think is it's all you know and uh
jeff dye making the debut here to my
left is jeff dye you guys know him he's
been on fire the kid he's been at
shobhan friends yeah you know i'm from
the tonight show you know from last
comic standing mr steele your girl brian
passed away so we got a much better
looking guy yeah brian complains about
the lighting and then you guys know
chris deleo yeah dude it's one o'clock
and i'm [ __ ] waking up dude this is
this is your dad daddy's been up daddy's
been up you wake up too early for a
comedian don't do it yep stay sleeping
longer it's killing me and it's
literally killing me now i've been up
for 30 minutes i know really 40 minutes
yeah when i was a kid it's one o'clock
show you guys like ah man it seems kind
of early yeah yeah i didn't think what
is wrong these were at night time you
know yeah they are but this is where in
london so it's like oh we're all [ __ ]
up somebody just died back yeah someone
got shot in the face that's cool um
yeah dude it's one o'clock i woke up at
11 30.
wow raced over here dude wow because
it's too far so got up well you live too
far yeah yeah wow i live in this the
mecca here yeah all right i don't know
if i'd say calabac calabasas is the
mecca i mean
no i don't know i think who lives here
okay but
mecca is crazy crazy uh
you're overshooting it you know it's a
nice place to live who kanye lives here
does he keep going yeah he lives here
just my house next door it is girl
yeah me that's about it that's why it's
the capital okay so thank you because
you're in the country that's good
there's a little more than that you saw
some gals they're one that i'd like to
live by right here
oh you went there up first yeah you got
up a little early well no not a little
early like 11 30 but i live closer than
you oh i live closer to the mecca bro
yeah you look close to the mecca man
yeah you're in yeah now we were uh we
were out i'm not too late last night we
had it was my birthday with a little
birthday dinner a little birthday
at iron man or yeah is it iron man yeah
we are at the tony stark's house i'd say
that was probably the best dinner i've
had oh no i i actually went home and i
told i told my girl i was like you know
what that was i think top five dinners i
i've ever had
it's nice i really do think that it was
nice i mean of all the dinners ever so
it was good i mean it was so good it was
good it kept being good too like all the
things yeah your boy broke like all the
things you know usually there's like one
thing you're like i'm not really a fan
of that but dude
it was so it's such a fancy meal i
didn't know what i was eating yeah i
think that's good i bet that was so good
i didn't care either nothing was funnier
my girl and our friends uh ryan and
charlotte were there we're talking about
uh like our moms and my girls mom's like
a straight up milf like dime piece like
really distractingly beautiful that's
ridiculous like at our pool she's in a
two-piece bikini i'm like mama you gotta
you gotta put your hair on this is which
is i think that's my body i'd say i'd
say my boat
let it rip
but then then my buddy ryan who's from
england was talking about his wife's
and he was like yeah hers isn't like
that man tits down here but jeff kept
egging it on
he was like oh you could tell he's like
oh we're i'm in the safe zone and just
dug himself a hole so dude
where they for sure fought when they
left
that's all he's saying
just saying your mom's ugly yeah you
left you did you do a set yeah yeah
it was fun though good group yeah it was
then i went to laugh factory and that
was fun and then i went home and i
stayed up way too late
yeah you text me at four four you're up
to four yeah what did you do at four no
he's a vampire no
what do you do i i don't stay up till
four my
kristen came
with me to the show and we went home we
went to the life factory and then there
were other people laughing we brought
them back to my house and i was just
like i'm so tired babe and she was like
no just have everybody over we had them
all over
some guy came over and like he found out
he was allergic to dogs and [ __ ] and his
eye got all puffed out that's on him
though you know no no no no but so we're
just inviting strangers back no no no i
know she knows oh you know oh you don't
want to say it
and uh and so yeah so it was just uh it
was so i stayed up and i was talking now
was uh was one of the friends uh because
i saw a picture on instagram with t.i
yeah
is he here or not no one ever see how
you're opening it yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's been doing some playing yourself
you've been powered ti now
um no wait have you done a show that
he's been on yet yes okay i don't wanna
you know i don't wanna because there's a
lot of people listening to this yeah
just between us yeah off the record you
know ti's terrible
garbage
let's let's clear this up that you
cannot
you can't do it for two weeks
and be good yeah i don't expect him to
be the funniest guy ever but he should
know he's dog [ __ ] no but yeah so
so you can't not
you can't not be dog [ __ ] you can't not
be it's not that you can't be good it
doesn't matter who you are you can't be
not be i'm not mad [ __ ] yes but he also
he he's at the laugh factory in the
store and it's like
you know he's jumping he's bumping like
you know he's jumping there like you're
pro pros man yeah like there's not a
better car i've never sang before maybe
i'll go to the greatest stages in the
world to do it that's exactly what we do
move over hey adele beat it we do a
quick 20. it's me from mtv at least but
no but he goes he goes uh on at the end
which is at least cool yeah so but then
people are waiting and they're like yeah
[ __ ] ti t.i
he gets that check drop spot yeah yeah
yeah i don't hate on him i mean if
that's what he wants to do but if he's
bumping like real cops off yeah at least
on the shows that he has not bothered
yeah but yeah i mean who am i to judge
like i mean honestly dude i always feel
like you know i know certain people get
so mad at like comics like like are
people that like curious comics get mad
and they're like [ __ ] why why does
somebody come in and do what i do for a
[ __ ] my whole life and just sidestep
it now they're on like i don't give a
[ __ ] dude especially in l.a like
people love seeing that [ __ ] like oh
[ __ ] they're like on vacation and
[ __ ] ti coming like that's crazy to
be like go back to like kentucky be like
yeah and then t.i came on and did a set
at the left like what but he has more of
a leash like say if he was in kentucky
because in la like the the standard for
comedy is so high for stand up so
they'll be like oh it's ti and then
after two minutes like dude you better
start yeah yeah
i'm not mad at him at all
whatever you want
they always say like they don't say he's
ti
okay so and then they don't no and then
last night i heard him say the host like
don't bring up his ti bring me up as tip
harris whatever tip harris yeah
his name's tip by the way or what is
that you know hey
i know what you're saying you know you
know what i'm saying okay but don't be
yeah but you know
yeah yeah but we're not gonna tip harris
sounds like a newsie
tip here sounds like what's right
and so um no so
so he says don't but then he goes on
stage and he's like
hey
i'm a uh he says basically he doesn't
say i'm ti but he's like but he does
like expeditiously and doing all the
stuff and he's like i made a song that's
a hit the thing and everyone's like
wait this is we thought you got a tip
yeah so
and also he's like kind of super famous
like his face
yeah so like it's like they don't bring
up his ti and people are just literally
the first thing they're doing and a half
they're like this is [ __ ] tia no they
probably
especially in hollywood they probably
think it's like a fake ti like a guy
doing like uh a bit about yeah yeah yeah
but so it's just we i'm like so i think
what i think is there's
real comics that are saying
dude don't use your t-i-ness right to go
on stage don't have him bring up his ti
which is [ __ ] stupid just he's ti
don't want to be like is he's going to
be tia it's not like he's 21 and he got
famous from something he's like 50 right
right right so it's like you're ti right
right he had a bunch of guns on him the
set i saw he had all these guns really
no no it's like jesus christ on stage
that really tipped everyone off you know
it was hilarious though so
this is hilarious so so my girl and then
my buddy's girlfriend and then two other
girls were the uh the photographer you
know this and then uh one of the other
comedians girlfriend were all hanging
out and they and then t.i had like his
posse and then they were like uh
the girls were talking and t.i went up
and the guys were like should be quiet
be quiet be quiet like to to everybody
and one guy says quiet on the set
quite on
he's live everybody he's live we're live
but whatever dude hey look if he's gonna
go on stage every night and [ __ ] try
then
well that's what that's where you earn
the respect right yeah like who am i to
judge that was my thing yeah i don't
know i know but that one right now is
part of it you know what real comments
giving them oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm not afraid of ti's fans going hey
man it's just i don't care he sucks now
and when he's good he can hang out i
suck two weeks in
cause he could hang out yeah yeah
yeah
he posted that picture with him i was
like oh okay yeah it was a good pick
yeah
dude i
like you know if i take a picture with
ti that's what's going on instagram it's
god i wonder but have you have you
talked like talk to him like what's the
move like is he like i'm trying to do
international tour i want to ask i want
to ask him because i wonder what the
move is because if he's like doing
stand-up and wants to do stand-up now
then yeah you just have to work so like
here's my thing
rap isn't famously the best sense of
humor no it's the unless you're a funny
unless you're a little unless you're a
little different like they never smile
they're always like you know what you're
making jokes funny boy you got joking
like hey man yeah i'm a comedian like
yeah i can't imagine a rapper going now
i'm a silly guy like that's
yeah unless you're like eminem or you
know somebody who does but then also uh
godfrey was going at t.i like they had
some weird beef and uh because i guess
godfrey was like yeah sounds important
yeah he was like yeah i shut that place
down then t.i you're gonna follow me
it's like oh my god but then uh ti goes
and does his thing and then he i guess
godfrey said something on a podcast like
talking [ __ ] about him and t.i was like
bro i'm not a like i'm not comedian like
i'm just a yeah i'm a rapper who's
telling stories like i'm trying my hand
at this thing yeah he's like when i'm in
the same lane dude yeah i don't consider
myself a comedian so then i'm like
alright do your thing dude
coffee is funny he he does well on stage
yeah oh yeah yeah
he's a beast yeah super beast yeah
well i just can't you know like like you
always teach you the first thing in
comedy like to self-deprecate you know
can you imagine a rapper trying to do
that no
no
no i mean you know not all those
bentleys in the music video are mine
yeah
that's a self-deprecation yeah right as
a fake diamond earrings i said i made 20
million but it was like 10 million
during the pandemic the crowd's like oh
no he uh
yeah you know i know i'm not the tallest
cat and like these aren't this isn't
self-different good man
um yeah i don't know what the move is
for him i really want to know i wonder
what the long game is like because he he
should be set right and he beat the case
with his wife with all that crazy maybe
went through a breakup and he's like yo
why did it end she's like you're not
funny and he's like oh he's like oh
really oh you don't think i'm funny yes
you ever heard of laugh you're rich
you're really success you know i like
you that you got drive but you never
made me laugh i need to go watch this
you know right yeah maybe yeah who knows
maybe maybe it's just challenge like
he's done rap he's done all that
[ __ ] so now it's like this is the
next thing
well really successful people like have
that in them you know they want to like
conquer like jamie foxx has done
everything yeah crazy he's a really good
comedian too he's on he does everything
yeah yeah i'm a great singer great actor
yeah nice guy big dick yeah i've heard
that wait what giant hammer bro yeah
i've heard that
wow what is happening on the television
well what is happening here this is the
the main cards kicking off this first
fight in the main card i always forget
how many fights are there is always
different there uh no there's always
five on the main card wow that's so many
so there's gonna be five fights right
now yeah but i only got to pick three
yeah what the [ __ ] the three main ones i
mean you guys can pick the other three
main ones or five main ones uh well
there's five on the main card but then
there's a main event co-main event but
here's the problem not the prom i'm glad
they did this but this card's stacked
for a free card cause patty pimlett is
like
he's the next
they're hoping he's the next conor
mcgregor yeah yeah yeah yeah he's a big
he's like our version of justin bieber
when he's 14. yeah yeah yeah
the face of the future face of the game
yeah like he's the next big big big
thing like he
he like he could sell out these arenas
before he was even the ufc such a big
star
like he just has all like he checks all
the boxes like really good obviously
really good fighter super talented no
he's entertaining though too yeah very
good puncher yeah he's just fun to watch
great haircut great haircut here yeah
yeah long hair cool hair
but he so how old is he yeah he's young
dude
before i think after his first fight is
this correction after his first fight in
ufc he signed a seven figure deal with
barstool yeah sports
27 20 27. he looks i thought he was
younger he looks way younger yeah
yeah but if he's that good he has to
have some experience behind him right oh
yeah but no because uh like the local
scene in uh london like in england is uh
is it uh cage of f is it was it cajo
fury chin
uh
something like that but that like connor
came out he had a bunch of monsters leon
edwards warriors cage warriors like it's
such a good like feeder into the ufc
yeah such good never lost oh no no he's
never tied
yeah he's an exciting kid he's
definitely even though he's like only
the third fight on the main card he's
definitely the most
famous like most
popular ones oh really you know who he
was before oh he's super famous yeah
i know he was bro i feel uncomfortable
calling any grown man a baddie
just call him patty yeah i'll call him
paddy yeah but fine with that daddy's a
little weird you know the baddie i go
come on man yeah come on man i wouldn't
i wouldn't [ __ ] that guy at all
he's not that much of a baddie but like
for fight fans like this card like all
the fights on the main card are like all
of them could be fighting knights like
as all the companions we've done one
versus five seven yeah that's intense
but all the fights we've done this
probably from like the for the five main
fights even though we did pay-per-views
this is to me the best card in a long
time
no hopefully the fan base fights bruce
buffer amazing suit but also in the ufc
this is the first time they've gone back
to london since coven so they sold o2
arena out in like seconds oh wow so it's
up in london like it's a big big deal oh
wow big deal
bruce that's cool
what's bruce buffer's catchphrase let me
in the office
nope that's his brother you know he
manages his brother yeah i heard that
yeah that i was just telling these guys
that i listened to some espn thing we
didn't even know they were brothers yeah
for a long time they're like friends
yeah
yeah i don't know if i believe that's
right but yeah that's what they said no
i know i saw that no i'm just joking i
believe bruce but um isn't it crazy
though it's like a weirdest story and
also bruce does so much more work so his
brother literally makes a million
dollars every time he goes
let's get ready to rumble
bruce has to [ __ ] work his ass oh
yeah in the red corner
you know at 11 and three fighting out of
wolverhampton england oh he's got to do
all that yeah he goes each card or each
game i fight every fight top to bottom
starting with the prelims to the stop
like he's he's working his trying to use
the terms you know the card yep fight
he's each fighting so wait sword wait so
uh and they did you say they didn't know
they were brothers what that yeah that's
the story that they did yeah like he
like thought he was she thought michael
buffer was cool and like he was just
like there's something about that guy
he's smooth he's slick they did that
right same day at different moms
is that insane yeah and then he helped
him with his career like michael buffer
lost all this money he's this man he
didn't lose money but there was money on
the table that he wasn't getting and he
helped him get it he's just managing uh
you know
i shot a commercial for my special with
bruce and he is as far as businessman
dude he has his hands in everything i do
a lot that dude everything so here
here's my bar soap here's my bourbon
here's my billy juice here's my energy
drink i'm like dude seems like just a
lot of work yeah
he's a great dude though cameo too oh
that's right
he came in here and he's like you mind
if i do some cameos i started making fun
he's like brenton you know how much
money i make doing this and told me i
was like oh [ __ ] i'll do that too if are
you yeah so hold on he well yeah him
he's hurt he was a voice dude video game
like actors and like uh like the guy who
does batman cartoons oh yeah those guys
clean up i heard the people that do the
best are the ironically famous people oh
really so like housewives anyone on
those dating shows like those are the
number one ones bruce makes like you
know yeah like six figures yeah every
month because think about you got a
birthday yeah yeah he's like how you
doing brendan
congratulations to your 39th birthday
you know
it's time it's your birthday anytime
there's a holiday oh jesus landed weird
oh he's crushing during holidays yeah
anytime there's a holiday i might pay
him do one for easter for my kids just
dress up as a bunny get all crunk wow
dude
that's a good idea that would be fun to
come over and do that
they could do that
man but there's nothing like a london
crowd that's why this is a big deal
that's why i want to do the fight
company like you know we don't do fight
fans for free cards usually we do
pay-per-views yeah but this one to me
top to bottom and i'm half english bomb
born and raised oh yeah
so be cool man no i always forget that
because you know yeah i could always
steam english at all no i look native
american you guys are bleeding already
it's been 20 seconds now jeff you uh
you don't you're not a big fight fan
right like you're you're more of
baseball i just don't know much about it
yeah i don't follow it but you never you
never got really into it at the
beginning i was when it was like super
gimmicky hollywood video we were talking
about here like ufc one you know
i was like karate guys first yeah yeah
yeah
i was like yeah yeah that [ __ ] was lit
it was yeah it was like and then they
all like oh we'll just learn all the
fighting styles and you're like oh
yeah then it got yeah i know it then it
was less exciting like super gimmicky
yeah i love the gimmick dude when it's
funny because joe rogan like hates pro
wrestling all that stuff yeah it kind of
felt like a video game in the beginning
it kind of felt pro wrestling
yeah
who had one bot he was a boxer and he
only had a boxing glove on his right
hand he had shoes on i remember that
they fought a sumo guy in the chair
yeah i was like yeah i like that mortal
kombat yeah when you were a kid it was
like oh this is insane honda versus yeah
dulcinea yeah but then you know you
gotta make it a real sports you get all
right trash yeah there it is look at
that wow
oh he's against that's gracie right yeah
that's voice gracie he lost
always gracie choked him out pretty
quickly boys gracie lost or beat balrog
wow always gracie b honda this is his
name wild yeah
ryu
uh that's crazy but you're look at how
bleedy i went to a laker game with jeff
and jeff is mr laker dude he yeah it was
insane i invited you to lick it i don't
know but he goes i don't i don't care no
no i'll come with you i will i will come
with you you're the only guy that i know
who's straight who's not into sports
like when they told me you were in
sports i was like oh chris likes dick
yeah well
is that weird cool but i don't
i just yeah no he wouldn't do dick for
sport no no no no um you've just never
been in even as a kid nothing i tried i
did basketball like when i was like i
really like baseball for a while the
thing i like about bait here's what i
like baseball
uh because you there's like so many
breaks in it and i'm like oh i like the
brakes
you know what i mean like if you were
like
yeah like it's slow it's like you're in
the dugout for a bit like oh we gotta go
out there
oh the offense we're on offense now but
only really one guy's doing it right
right i mean so like
chill i was like oh maybe i just don't
like sports dude i hope your son's like
mr sports but that'll probably happen
yeah i hope he is too man like i want
him to like whatever like you know the
only reason i got into sports is because
i grew up in a house full of chicks
right and so like any boy thing was cool
to me yeah like they're like all the
kids are like well let's play baseball
like baseball's like a dude thing yeah
what a fight i want to do anything that
was like not the girl [ __ ] that was
happening in my house because your
sister's like dressed like this
like girls
well they tried to and i was like i'm
not doing it with lipsticks
there was a couple times yeah they
dressed me up when i was real young yeah
i saw photos of it you know i remember
it just like i blocked it out yeah
that's what you want to do my uncle
creeped in there
it was your brother
this is a wait this is a crazy height
difference what makes a guy bleed so
much
some guys have a lot of scar tissue so
when they get hit like they're more
prone to bleeding that's why you can't
go he's not these drummers he was
bleeding from his chest and then he
could
yeah oh that guy's like his chest
deported he's really swinging for the
fences
yeah some guys have like scar tissue
from all the training and stuff so they
cut easy so
he landed a big one there but uh that's
why you can't judge a fight based off of
like
blood you can't be like oh that guy's
losing he's all cut up he's like well he
might be more prone to being cut and
stuff like that like they say blood is
deceiving
yeah there's an old fight term no yeah
i've heard that that makes sense i live
by that
you you do now can you only bring one
person to the laker again i could
probably bring more yeah multiple
friends i mean me and chris and the
three of us that have so much fun there
yeah podcast there
your podcast yeah with genie well i i've
said this before i don't think i've ever
said it publicly but like i'm hardly
watching the game yeah having we talked
the whole time
dude he
he's so [ __ ] [ __ ] you know it's jd
boss she owns the [ __ ] lakers dude
she's trying to watch his game he's like
who are you talking to about uh who's
got rid of caruso cruz he's in our area
he's like you know he [ __ ] up right
getting rid of crew so it's like
it's a big deal man crucial's in chicago
you know she should know so funny though
she's the best i'm like what is he doing
yeah she's the best yeah and she's like
so nice about everything she'll tell us
crazy stories where i'm like how come
you didn't tell that like because she's
been on my podcast i'm like how come you
didn't tell that in a bucket she goes it
just happened like a few weeks ago i was
like oh well she's come back she's she's
great she's an open book yeah she's
she's the nicest chicken she's so cool
they say she's the brains behind the
lakers
she's the blood of the lakers man now
well i do like this about it too she's
like so like humble in the way that like
you know like if lebron waved at us or
something i'd be like that was pretty
cool yeah lebron waved to us she like
she acts like a fan when i'm like you
own these guys yeah cool though you pick
like they'll be like they'll like they
don't say you own the guys but yeah you
know they don't hear you you're on the
team right these basketball you own that
guy yeah yeah yeah yeah well yeah i own
these men no matter what race they are
it's not a thing
yeah you know the caruso was a white guy
you owned yeah you got rid of them
i was gonna wear my cooper cup jersey
but i was like ooh chris can light me up
if i wear another man's jersey oh yeah i
don't even know who that is so cooper
cup is a 510 white cup is a golf
tournament right uh
yeah in phoenix no but he is a cooper
cup he's a basically i'll give him six
foot six foot white guy from eastern
washington and he's the best receiver in
the nfl really yeah so show some [ __ ]
respect just won the super bowl super
bowl champion well also nfl mvp
offensive and oh that's right he
shouldn't have got that mvp though he he
shouldn't have well
let's talk about what he's done that's
not that should have though he she he
earned it so good for him he won but i'm
saying like that final play with aaron
donald
that would have been a big
let me cut the touchdown to
oh wow we dropped him oh [ __ ] oh that
was hard oh [ __ ] he really dropped him
hard instantly he was a big favorite too
and we have the same nose so that's cool
oh wow yeah no he's [ __ ] god damn it
that one shot right there did you see it
chin no
it looked bad though do you guys do like
a blog where you document your guys's
opinions about these guys a blocker no a
blog no we're no blog
i want to have like a little panel on
the side where i get to review their
tattoos oh yeah yeah that's hilarious
totally not related just me being a jerk
about their tattoos goddammit there's a
lot of tats these guys there's more you
know what peeking through here's a good
question right here right here
whoop
what no no
oh it's a good body shot oh right hook
yeah filthy
yeah
that's so sad when you see their eyes
just like yeah it's like they're looking
at a painting i want to warn all your
listeners and watchers that i'm going to
say a lot of cliches like right on the
button
things like that it can't be any worse
than brian brian go man he's going to be
sweating
yeah every time we've been doing i don't
know these guys are so athletic yeah man
these guys are tough oh they got
bispings excuse me
yeah this thing's great all right he's
got a gladiator on his arm
a tiger i like this guy's tattoos yeah
me too it's pretty cool
is that now is he a nurse is that a
nurse tattoo down the back yeah he's a
nurse he's an emt that's the guy that
got into scuffle with patty pimblett
yeah yeah
yeah is there some tweet that patty had
about about russia uh yeah georgians in
russia yeah it was not the best thing
but
what did it say
i had it up earlier
was it at least funny yeah that's all i
care about so pimless tweet which uh has
been a responder fan said lad how stupid
are these georgians man alongside a
series of crying laughing emotions
before adding no wonder the russian
terrorized their lives
okay
and then uh
this rubbed topera the wrong way
tweeting last april you think that's
funny in that attack by russia against
this many of them people lost their
lives oh i'm yeah this makes sense [ __ ]
children the one who supports terrorism
and racism is one of them this tweet
will haunt you for life now and then
here's the thing about uh that guy when
he saw him in the hotel he wanted to
fight him on the spot right there
now to patty's defense he did throw a
punch and pat he slipped it and then him
in the face with a water bottle so is
that true it's talented yeah even even
in the hotel lobby the kids get super
talented kids got speed
now i understand why russia destroyed
georgia because you're dumb dude you
kind of want to stay out of politics you
know if you're fight like unless you
know you're [ __ ]
i mean it's just such a toxic where you
don't jump in there man it's it's
dangerous yeah dangerous you can't wait
what's going on in atlanta georgia that
he's talking about
i also didn't yeah
yeah it's probably that mall that i went
through out there
happy hippo oh yeah
oh did you say happy hippo yeah i'm glad
you brought it up dude listen
to jeff thank you for bringing that up
yeah dude i'm unhappy hippo right now
dude no but yeah it's my limitless pill
bro what's going on dude oh thank you
for asking happy hippo right yeah dude
it's kratom it's kratom and it's pure
kratom and kratom you can't trust it
from everywhere you can only trust happy
hippo i use it to fire up my brain
before everything like your brain seems
like yeah yeah okay do i put eye drops
how do i put happy hippo in my body dude
what i like to use the shot so the pink
lemonade shots i take one shot and
daddy's ready to go i turn to elon musk
for about 20 minutes and then it runs
out i'm back to stupid it's the best
focused product i've ever used best part
it's all natural visit happy hippo
herbals.com use promo code sickboy for
20 off for life kids that's thick boy is
the promo code 20 off for life use as
many times as you want everybody hears
on it we're having fun
um you say herbal still huh yeah yeah
it's herbal but it's herbal or herbal
well they should have put an h in front
of them no i know
and well because i speak portuguese
english right so they do say herbal
actually so yes there you go in england
that's how we say it okay
in english that's how we say it well i'm
not
but yeah it's fine i just you know died
i'll control my anger thank you for
those exact
you know what really you know what jeff
usually wears what do you always wear
your [ __ ] so i know but it's casually
yeah you wear your st
now i'm proud of them here you just got
a lot more respect yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah the presto
did you hike and he wears them did you
hike
whenever i need sneakers these are what
i wear wow don't wash them either do you
know how much those are worth now uh
yeah i bought these you have any idea
how much it was worth i was at i was in
vegas and i needed sneakers so how much
did you pay for them 1500 or something
like that
yeah that was like 2 000 now probably at
least 2 3 000 but this was like uh
i don't know
i love that three years ago i've had
them for a long time i was gonna buy
those and my girlfriend at the time i
was gonna pay for 500 bucks for them and
she was like you buy those that's so
[ __ ] stupid like that's so much money
and i was like i won't [ __ ] buy him
jesus christ jokes on her now the times
have changed huh
oh jeremy piven is there at the fight
[Laughter]
what is he staring right in the lens huh
that guy dude act like you've been there
[ __ ] lunatic
look at this guy who's this guy
yeah he was a great fighter man he was a
good fighter they all have great names
brad pickett the europeans like tiffany
what's up chip's name
tip tip tip hair
a lot of good names i wish we had a cool
nickname
have you had any cool names drago
terrible nicknames
jeff dyson's pretty yeah you nicknames i
mean i had one you're the wing yeah yeah
yeah well i don't have any nicknames now
i'm [ __ ] 41. no what are you talking
about your nickname's the winner no i
know but people don't say actually i was
at the gas station the other day and so
i was like hey the wing
bro so there you go it's catching up bro
i'm gaining popularity i was at er one
yesterday picking up food between the
shows this 50-something year old lady
comes up to me and he goes hey oops
don't rip chris anymore right hell yeah
dude she was being made a mistake right
yeah she started laughing as hard she
was made a mistake right yeah i watched
the 50.
you left a little drag time just to bait
him in on that
what do you mean the clip we saw yeah
you
there was like a
i don't know if i was going to ride away
i let him in yeah you you you left a
little
and then no dude
it's like no it's like hopscotch and you
let you you know it's like really and i
saw an opportunity and i was like oh
we should talk about your youtube
comments they're critical of real weird
things yeah sometimes
life ain't fair or is it that they're
not looking at it right because you're
growing and your penis isn't so it's not
necessarily smaller
i didn't
oh i'm i'm with jeff on this system let
you breathe i didn't i wasn't breathing
i was in the middle of [ __ ] talking
you know you know
it's a relay it's a relay and i'm like
this waiting and i thought you were done
but you were gonna continue to run on
when i see you in the wing waiting and i
have more to say i have to [ __ ] talk
even faster because i'm like here he
[ __ ] comes daddy's jumping in
cannonball ready with the oops
outside yeah you were ready
i'm always ready with you because you're
used to the laughter
yeah i know you're used to though like a
sea of light you never you don't go oops
to your audience when they laugh over
you no no no over the punchline oops hey
it wasn't done what are you doing here
i'll wait until you're done laughing
yeah yeah i get mad at you yeah usually
the oops is towards brian cowan because
he'll do it a lot oh yeah i interrupt
all the time well
we always have [ __ ] to say you know
we're coming yeah i get it sometimes i
can't wait but i'm getting better i used
to be way worse at it yeah i remember
rogan's like dude you gotta let people
talk oh really especially if it's
one-on-one he's like you gotta learn i
don't even try yeah i'm getting i'm
getting better at it i've only been
doing it for nine years i was only i
wasn't even good at a dinner last night
it was something if i thought of
something i was like
funny man i was good [ __ ] funny
that's how i talk it's how people talk
yeah yeah
look at the size of this creep that's
your friend god yeah that tyson fury's
the man oh you know him yeah he's gonna
fight a house what's he talking about
here well he's the best boxer in the
world yeah he helped ask him all too
yeah great yeah he used to train with
asthma he's the main event this kid
they're hoping is like the next big
thing in heavyweight i feel bad picking
against this guy and him looks like
they're really rooting for him
but it's a tough fight it's a tough
fight for him man because
i mean look at the guy on the right
could he be anything but a [ __ ] co
he's a coach right or whatever yeah was
that mickey from [ __ ] rocky exactly
exactly what he means is might be
where's aspinall from uh he's from
london look at hospitals
yeah so this guy's interesting because
he's
i think he's 4-0 in the ufc but he
hasn't fought anybody really good but
anybody that he's starch that guy on the
right is from uh godsmack anyways
bro this guy slipknot oh no he's a
slipknot this guy wins look at him he
should like to be honest like as far as
the odds go he should he's more
experienced he's beat overeem for doom
like he has a lot more experience but
i'm they're hoping that us aspinall is
the next big thing he just hasn't it's
tough because
you know he's a prospect and he's 4-0 in
the ufc and he's starched everybody he's
faced really and he hasn't beat anybody
in the top ten so then ufc's it's like
sink or swim yeah they're like all right
here's volkov dude number six in the
world that's crazy oh they're gonna let
ladies fight
jeff just they both have to fight these
two guys jeff's like when did women
start fighting
why did she give her that she said
that's nothing to me oh she was talking
[ __ ] she's like i'm ugly
oh [ __ ] oh my goodness now the other
hell yeah the vibe i'm here for yeah
she's she's pretty big in uh in england
she's university favorite she's a fan
favorite her uh no no no
yeah the english gal
wait so this is next oh
yeah this is next surprises on the main
card but she is a draw out there fans
love her
not a lot of people i think they call
her uh what's her nickname meatball
meatball meatball molly
we copyright meatball we got a meatball
here
meatball do we copyright your name
well meatball's kind of a thing i don't
know if you can
i don't know
you get your lawyer on it man it doesn't
sound like you did you know i think also
if we copyrighted your parents don't get
any of that yeah it's our idea tell your
dad that
the uh meat wad that's a thing meatwad
yeah from uh that cartoon oh right yeah
what carter never occupied that
what what cartoon so that's a cartoon
hunger dude i never got that
cartoon it was funny and cool yeah i
thought it was pretty funny
can you tell me why i don't know what is
this like when i watch like anime with
people and i don't get it are you saying
no i'm not stoned or anything he's just
funny
wow
what the [ __ ] is i've never heard oh hey
look it's your favorite [ __ ] person
oh [ __ ] leto in a marvel movie i can't
wait oh he did great last time as joker
he's good he's a great actor
but he's not he wasn't a good joker i
terrible completely disagree all right
well they didn't give him his fair shot
so but somebody has to be wrong in a
conversation right and it's you yeah no
he won an oscar he's a terrorist he won
an oscar in the thing he was good at
acting
no in that [ __ ] doubt
it was terrible as the joker yeah i
disagree he didn't get a no dude they
edit so much they had it so much he
could have his own joker movie that they
were supposed to release but they didn't
that's fine but then do that but in that
movie
he was bad i disagree i think it was the
editing was brought
name a bad movie he's done dude
was [ __ ] atrocious
and it's because of him the second one
no it was all bad
that movie what was it suicide squad
that movie was [ __ ] so bad i hate i
hate like comic book movies i know
spider-man or batman but i liked suicide
squad the second suicide dude that movie
first of all they introduced people for
45 minutes i love it no it's a buildup
it's bad the build-up you're [ __ ]
[ __ ] bad dude you're a hater i don't
think you really like here's the guy
yeah that's the other thing i actually
think that you don't like the movie i
promise i do i think jared leto made the
movie you're a [ __ ] goddamn he's in
it for like seven minutes i know dude
you know he shot enough whether he'd had
his own joker movie bro that is not an
argument for him acting good yeah but
there's more footage on him it doesn't
matter he was so he
like the joker like how you would it was
just like how that [ __ ]
eight-year-old would be like that's the
joker dude [ __ ] heath ledger did well
what's his uh who else jack nicholson oh
yeah i mean that was just hilarious he
was hilarious joker jack because you
know who else there's another joker
right oh oh oh oh joaquin phoenix he
killed it oh joaquin vincent i mean yeah
but that day yeah no uh what's his name
that uh from adam west days no not that
yeah
there's gonna be six fights on the car
tonight if you [ __ ] keep talking
about the most famous joker like uh he's
not the best joker what's the second one
he's ledger heath legends you named him
five minutes i know i know but that's
the best one oh joaquin phoenix was the
best i see i think that guy's the best
caesar romero the mexican joker yeah
hey that's me and white face that's me
and white face right now it does look
pretty that is pretty pretty
my stand-up career goes south that's
what i'm starting doing jack nicholson
was great he was fantastic yeah michael
keaton is my batman there you go how
about mark hamill's luke skywalker
whatever the cartoon doesn't count the
cartoon doesn't count he thought it was
that's gotta be number one he's legend
was fantastic honestly i think he drove
him bananas and he killed himself or
whatever i think heath ledger was great
it's pretty good but i don't think he i
i think everyone says weirdos he's uh
the best because the best way
no i i just i don't take
i don't know if it's because he passed
away but i just
he was good he was really good but
joaquin phoenix was just
unbelievable here's why joaquin phoenix
is the best because he was three hours
of the joker [ __ ] heath ledger was in
i don't know barely pretty good points i
got to get enough of them here so i
wanted more yeah but heath ledger or
maybe we're just debating on who wrote
the best joker because that no the heath
ledger he was a badass he could like he
was people afraid of him he was psycho
he almost murdered those people on boats
he put the one guy's eye through a
pencil he's beating up guys doubling out
spawn how do you remember all this why
do you two but then the uh jared leto
not jared leto but the one you guys are
referencing yeah
he just danced around all creepy and he
never really he killed one fat guy
yeah but that movie was wasn't scary to
me i killed that it was so good
brian's in that movie for literally
three seconds
he's longer than i was in it no
dude that's
in that movie too
[Laughter]
i think that he
you know that makes him happy yeah yeah
he's like the joker he wants you to hate
him yeah exactly yeah he should have
played the joker i wish i could bottle
up your loyalty and sell it to people
that you would defend that jared leto's
joker because you just love jared leto
all defensively and he said that he
would he made the movie yeah he's a
loyal dude yeah yeah no uh which is good
yeah but he just wasn't he was he was
just
not good i think that he was she was
screwed from the beginning because he
had to follow heath ledger's joker true
correct and he's like how do i make it
totally different i'll make it kind of
this like sexier kind of slicked back
guys yeah but i also think that i also
think that you have to
um
i think jared leto is a really good
actor and i think that the best actors
sometimes do the worst because they're
trying something give me another example
because joaquin phoenix
i always like i think one of the
greatest actors is nick cage and that
guy makes some crazy choices if you like
make some horrible movies too but that's
what makes you daddy needs anything yeah
that's why nick cage i like nick cage
once said he goes just pay my rate i'll
do your movie yeah so that let ev like
all the people couldn't judge no more
because they go well they paid us right
it's a bad script bad director but they
paid so now he never has to be
criticized for anybody
i love him because he uh will buy like a
t-rex skull for seven million dollars
he'll buy like an eagle his accountant's
like dude living life is a bad idea yeah
like how many shitty movies you're gonna
have to do to pay off this [ __ ] t-rex
yeah it's a t-rex skull yeah and then he
started investing in like castles he
bought a bunch of chassis he's hilarious
yeah i love him you know my theory on
why jared leto's joker sucked okay dude
you wanna okay what do you got i think
he tried to make him hot
and joker's not supposed to be hot
that's cool though no jeremy no they're
all caught but you can't
you know he's 50 dude i know have you
heard him sing
i i want to tell you this right now joke
no but i want to tell you this right now
dude go ahead say whatever you say
because i have something to fight you
this is fine
i get it and i'll lose 30 seconds to
mars
i'm i not only have i i never heard
jared leto sing oh wow i will never
ever hear jared leto sing oh you know
what oh you're not going to go to his
cult camp no and that's [ __ ]
horseshit because i think he knows i
have a cult and he kind of copied me
uh i don't give a [ __ ]
you know what i feel bad for you okay
you're missing out that's fine dude
seems like a goddamn angel
he acts very great the ladies are
fighting
the ladies are fighting and meatball is
doing well she's a fan favorite and this
girl's like oh [ __ ]
her head keeps bouncing the black chick
is like what but the white chick is a
fan favorite uh big time yeah big time
her and patty are like really big fan
favorites
honestly what's controversial
nothing what's controversial is
controversial
did you know what's controversial chin
yeah no
no in that country oh it's in that
country i was like i don't think it's
controversial
in that country virtual ginger country
it was like my english friends last
night they're like what is a fork oh
gosh yeah you know [ __ ] they were so
sweet and nice and fun but it wouldn't
matter what reference to like
what do you call
what is
who is michael jackson you're like it's
a very famous podcast they're like this
michael jordan yeah they didn't know
anything what is it that's a peach
was it for a candy it was amazing
they were sweethearts though no yeah
they're they're you know when you become
parents and your friends or in your son
has a best friend you hang out with
those parents just around them all the
time they're like you're only no those
people were wrapped yeah they're great
yeah we haven't said their names so i
don't feel bad saying that the uh the
woman [ __ ] in kim kardashian's house
that's a big deal
i don't remember that's a pretty big
deal i thought you did no no i didn't i
don't know what shit's in that house oh
yeah
they don't even know the kardashians
don't have don't eat this [ __ ] yeah they
don't have [ __ ] i was pretty
impressed by that yeah she said that she
goes actually they're whoa like what you
wow you [ __ ] in their house really
upgraded for you huh
we don't know what's their name though
so it's off you know what yeah you know
what i don't is uh uh i don't i [ __ ]
wherever i gotta go dude you know how
people are like oh i don't i gotta go
home to [ __ ] no no dude you don't do
that i'm the opposite i i'm exclusively
poop in public yeah i'd rather do doing
that in my house it's dirty yeah i don't
want to blow up my bathroom no i'll just
where everybody else has got my problems
yeah yeah starbucks enjoy this yeah hey
but will you do it on a plane chris yeah
me too yep it's really hard you know
what i like to do i'm i'm in there for a
hot second cause i'm on my phone
and i come out so bad and i pre oh dude
it's a nightmare i'm sweating i come out
i'm all sweaty i think until i did work
in there i pretend i'm on the phone i'm
like you do what right really oh no
that's not a big deal yeah i pretend
like you're on a plane they're like
there's no way he has a call up here
yeah yeah not me dude i don't know every
time the phone i get out and if there's
a line i walk by and i take a moment to
look into everyone's eyes
kiss them
and i look at them and i go you know and
and it's basically like i know i know
what happened you know what happened all
good dude be cool be cool yeah one time
i was in the bathroom and somebody uh
was you know this is what i [ __ ] do i
was at the coffee bean you know how i
like to go to coffee bean or whatever
yeah and so i'm at the coffee bean and i
like to go to the i was like okay i
gotta go i gotta go to the bathroom i'm
gonna use the [ __ ] bathroom and i i
go in i lock the door the lock was a
little janky and i'm like all right
[ __ ] whatever i'm gonna lock the door
as best i can so i lock the door and i
go and i'm going to number two and the
freaking thing jiggles and i'm like yeah
i'm in here sorry so then sorry oh i get
silent
oh okay so i go
so they keep jiggling no i just pretend
like i just oh no no not me man i hide
no not me i don't hide well there's
nowhere to hide dude you're in a little
box i know but in my head i hide you
know and so uh i get the the lock
jiggles jiggle jiggle jiggle i'm like
all right [ __ ] you know i'm still in
here like what do you want still here
here's the other thing you see me leave
here's the other thing too when you're
in the bathroom and someone knocks okay
i'm in here and then someone knocks
again like i rest ashore rest
a [ __ ] shore i am not in this
shitty room
any longer than i
need to or want to be i want to get out
of here very quickly yeah this room i'm
not chilling in here this room sucks
yeah it's okay so you're not small
either so they're knocking the door
knocking on the door and i'm like what
the [ __ ] and then they jiggle the lock
and i'm like the lock's not safe yeah
so it's gonna open and i'm sitting there
and i i can't do anything like it's too
far away i can't reach it so i'm like
it's gonna open up so i'm just gonna
[ __ ]
i'm gonna man up whatever happens if
they were able to open the door because
if they keep doing it it's gonna open
the door i'm just gonna [ __ ] stare
right at you flex your ass i'm gonna
just be right there just [ __ ] yeah
aggressive and sure enough it happens
boom in walks in dude this girl's like
11 years old and i'm like oh my god
that's why she didn't know yeah now i
felt so bad
she tried to piece so bad well
i was sitting in the window seat and
whenever the person falls asleep i'm
just like i feel so bad for him oh
really i i have to oh yeah i hate to i
know you just fell asleep
but that's the rule i get it if i'm on
the if i'm on the other side and bro i
got it i'm like i get it
a lot
yeah yeah come and go come and go oh i
drink a lot of coffee before i hit that
plane so we're too we're talking if it's
a three hour trip dude three four times
then really you're getting up and down
up and down up and down you know the
rule okay i'm private if you're gonna
piss that much okay no but i just love
the idea they're like well i would say
something anybody's a goddamn giant
gotta let the giant pee again
i would be making all these side remarks
just get around
anyone else notice frankenstein's gotta
piss again
just me just my role
that's funny wait so uh do you guys know
anything about these gals
mama can pretty much is winning this
round yeah
meatballs been whooping that ass
she has so much
different you know yeah now jeff you
don't know any of the female so have you
seen like paige van zandt or rachel
ostavidge or pearl gonzalez my buddy
tyler barker's really into this stuff
and he there there was a little stuff
but yeah well are you really into this
yes this art form yeah thank you it's
beautiful thank you uh but there was one
photo i don't know if he showed it to me
someone showed me there goes this girl
who fights who's just gorgeous but then
she just covered herself in like tons of
tattoos and stuff like that i like that
that makes them harder like crazy
tattoos
ufc yeah blonde girl
not page unit cover not
uh she's probably like the hottest chick
i've ever seen in fighting for sure uh
yeah i wonder how how many tricks you've
seen there's some really uh what were
the best ones
blonde fighter covered in tattoos woman
oh
uh beck rawlings let me see oh back
rolling but but not on her face though
right she had like little ones in her
eyes and stuff oh yeah this is
backgrounds let me see i'm trying to
think who else has tattoos on their eyes
she was really pretty because i was
thinking like well you know it's
probably like
you know like her
no but she's pretty she's pretty yeah
she's just bare knuckle now she's a
badass so like i always think like
people go oh that jeff dies hot for a
comedian you know like so i thought when
they said like good looking lady i was
like yeah if you're a fighter she's
kidding me
oh
rachel
pearl gonzalez like
brian ortega's girl maybe she wasn't
blonde maybe this is her
jesse jess that's what i'm
thinking hot this is she she's very good
and that's not even good you know they
call her little thick put her up put her
up put up a different shot ass fighter
too little she's my buddy yeah she's my
buddy you got to get her uh
yeah these are the photos i saw she was
selling little thick shirts yeah oh no
she's a badass she's australian
yeah i'll get a feisty too
yeah she's hot i'd rather watch her
though she's smoking
yeah is she a ufc again yeah she is
she's a badass okay real badass she
lives out here actually
yeah she's a great person
man you know
yes man you're [ __ ] everybody huh
yeah it's kind of like comics yeah yeah
yeah i don't know what you're in the
club and like your alumni and then i you
know i do shows with fighters all the
time
right right
now speak of the shows i'll be in
phoenix
dude
daddy's doing a big showing for you yeah
i'm doing a phoenix show april 30th go
to chrisley.com you know and i'll be
there i love where i live phoenix
when are you there april 30th i'm there
thank god i'm there april 14th oh yeah
cool oh you're playing uh stand up live
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i love that club yeah how many shows are
you doing there five oh that's a great
club yep i'm in chicago this week though
thursday friday saturday chicago march
24th through 26th your boys in chicago
this crew will be at the improv
wednesday night though shop and friends
with these guys some other monsters one
show only at the hollywood improv 8pm
shout out to hollywood improv man i
[ __ ] love that yeah i love that but
after that thursday friday saturday i'm
in chicago come get some and then
phoenix is april 14th to the 16th and
then just announce if you uh the big
birthday post yesterday on friday for my
birthday this is cool i'm headlining the
moon tower comedy festival in austin
texas cap city april 22nd through 23rd i
have a very special guest there as well
so come get some man tickets at
fatkz.com or thickboy.com now jeff you
said you were good looking for comedian
don't you think you're good looking as a
now you're whatever yeah you just oh
that's nice but i just meant like you
know i know i know people say yeah
you'll go to like an audition like and
they'll be like yeah there's dudes
there's seven models you go oh god yeah
but you don't want to be that those guys
are not though i know i know i don't
think it's like hater but dude models
bro they're chairs i always say the girl
just sits on you and you suck and you
don't have to develop her personality
they're coat hangers
bro i think a lot of pro athletes are
like that i feel bad
like friends are a bunch of baseball
players because they don't have to
develop the personality because they're
spoon fed their entire lives because
either they're really good looking or
they're so good at sports the culture of
the sport isn't like real playful and
silly so they go in the clubhouse you
can't be goofing off and jacking around
like there's a few guys that do but yeah
in general they don't yeah yeah but
they're you know what there are they're
pranksters and that's not funny i know
you can't hit me in the nuts while i
walk by
like the funniest guy in the baseball
team's the guy with like a big beard
yeah isn't he a crack up yeah yeah he
has a huge beard in the bullpen you're
like that's not funny i just have a big
beard and some of those guys are real
smart but the thing is that you don't
have to be if you can [ __ ] go yard
you know what i mean you can just
[ __ ] smash they're not like trout
it's not like none of it
it's like it's like a hot it's like a
super hot chick most of them
are vapid yeah because they don't have
to develop a personality most of them
are lizards with lipstick but
but you're right but you can't but you
but when you meet a [ __ ] smart hot
chick oh
but don't chill there now [ __ ] yeah
turn girl good time to smile to the
crowd she went like this yeah she's like
yeah oh yeah he was dabbing people but
to your point they don't have to hold on
an airbnb story
stupid [ __ ] commercials how come
there's no good commercials dude it's so
easy the thirty [ __ ] no one's watching
them no one's watching them anymore well
they're awesome they were never good you
ever dude i watched a compilation of 90s
uh
commercials those were the best that
[ __ ] was weird
they were breaking anyway
stories like the ipad monster commercial
was lit the nintendo the advertiser
airbnb
we need yeah for airbnbs no no no no but
we don't want to do airbnb
they need some sort of regulation dude
because some of the airbnbs i get it's
like let me know it's in the hood right
the pictures are great let me know my
head needs to be on a swivel and i can't
wear red that day right what i'm saying
like let me know in my notes but you
know not to wear i'm gonna make a real
airbnb commercial yeah do it dude oh
yeah that's good hey dude look the birth
of the bit right here
jeff you didn't give your dates oh yeah
and uh i'm in sarasota florida
uh what is that this weekend this guy
goes to florida everybody i know
in florida it's like brian with [ __ ]
minneapolis oh he's there all the time
florida's a big state though so sarasota
florida uh march 25th 26th and 27th i
don't think those are sold out yet but
mccurdy's comedy club come see me uh
then i'm doing march 31st centralia
washington at the juice box one show
only it's gonna be fun i think uh the
next one is april 1st portland oregon
and uh
oh wait and bend
you're all over today i know i love that
you don't know no but those two dates
are like a fundraiser that i'm supposed
to be plugging real hard but i've been
sick all week uh
let me
come out look it up please please come
don't be tough oh boy what are we doing
it'd be tough to finish a chunk stand
like that yeah yeah and she only got the
strength that chick has been pushed all
over the world has been beating up
breaks off this year from the beginning
she pushed her head up against that top
i wonder why they call her meatball
because she's not really meaty so all
right so compared to this one she is
can
can she beat up can these girls beat up
a normal dude like maybe like you guys
no right you got to give me three weeks
well i've i've i've i mean it's not that
long i mean i'm out of shape to learn
but i did [ __ ] five six years of
[ __ ] i know
so i'm talking about a regular dude that
knows nothing about fighting that's me
is it i'm a regular guy there's nothing
yeah could these girls beat up jeff die
they're 125 by the way one twenty one
no no no are you if jeff landed like are
you like a haymaker right hook it'd be
[ __ ] true i know that's why it would
be like really you know what i'm saying
but even
but even if they get a whole brother but
even if they get a hold of him he's so
much i mean he's stronger yeah yeah it'd
be tough i could grab their stupid
little finger oh she knocked her out oh
she's in bed yeah wait what
dude you got to raise your hand stupid
get back in there if you were the
fighter oh she's hugging she's going to
hug for the bonus bro if you were the
fighter but i figured out what kind of
fighter i want to be now she's stealing
no the fans belt
you know what the changes cost 225
i figure out the price i figure out the
kind of fighter i want to be
you win right if i was a good fighter
you go in you you win as soon as you win
you run
pack up your [ __ ] and go home you just
go home and then you as soon as you get
in bed you take a selfie and you put on
instagram you've been in bed already and
it's like whoa that was 30 minutes if
you throw that close to the right
actually it'd be better if you would
have tried to take the photo earlier
and just went to the locker in the
locker room post the photo they're like
he's already embedded yeah that'd be
cool that was one minute that's
hilarious
that's knocked out of the night she's
getting 50k
what's that so the ufc awards uh bonuses
like fight of the night before the night
that you know that's going to be
definitely a performance of the night
did you notice that the ref pushed her
off by pushing her boob away
hey man whatever it takes
whatever it takes she said back off that
was a great knockout pushed your boob
away
spinning [ __ ] elbow knockout
no shoe i'm talking about run i'm
talking about running into your car yeah
like not even just like fast walking
like so
like you're sprinting to your car i
think jeff's going to go go go go go go
i think jeff's makes more sense than you
post the picture in bed because let's
say you live in brazil and you fought in
vegas yeah you're just like home already
everyone's like so confused that was fun
night yeah that's one good night
everybody
boom watch the ref pushes the boob away
watch he goes get out of here titty
he does that's assault brother
straight push dude
that was pretty cool to watch but do you
think that the girl's gonna like come to
and then be like when's the fight herm
padme boys
i gotta tell you though um
that back
elbow thing that i see sometimes
fighters do savage that is that is i
think
should be illegal that it no i think
that's the worst thing to get caught
with head kick you know what's worse no
no i don't mean
physically it hurts sometimes whatever
i'm saying oh this guy i'm saying it's
like almost like oh [ __ ] oh yeah you
know what i mean like we can't really
you're like you're not gonna like in
camp nobody's doing spinning elbows
right right right you just don't right
right right right so you get caught with
it's like god damn it's just so annoying
it's like it's like an extra thing that
almost shouldn't be there but it's like
it's such she just ended a woman's life
maybe career or whatever with the same
elbow that has a tattoo of like a
ballerina dancing with her does she have
it on there yeah her name's the meatball
dude she's a fan favorite now
she's got like a a ballerina dancing on
a oh and a [ __ ] not that a lot of
these fighters have the worst tattoos
look at the tattoos right there it's
like oh yeah it is a little balanced
that's exactly what she hit her with
boy michael bisping is a powerful rolex
daytona look at him grabbing up on her
like that hey don't move bisping is tell
us what you thought i [ __ ] liked that
dude i don't know him
i like that looks cool he's a good dude
you know talk to him
yeah he's a good dude he did like a live
kind of stand-up like story thing in
england yeah but he's a good funny dude
yeah
are there any ufc guys you don't like
yeah
me no i sort of i would tell you know me
yeah no i figured no there's none that's
good what a cool business i mean i'm
sure that i'm sure there's some who have
issues with me like people think i have
issues with dana zero issues really zero
that's cool i don't have issues look at
everybody i don't have issues with any
comics crack look at the ballerina elbow
right there it's too much energy to
[ __ ] hate somebody i just i can't do
i don't i don't have a dude back with
that dancing elbow comics are weird
though bro comics are weird comic it
comes to weird like jealousy thing you
know i'm sure fighters are weird too
dude at least at least you take it out
you're like it's a fight you know yeah
but those [ __ ] bro so you know yeah
comics like it's like this jealousy
thing like they think because you have
this it's because they don't it's like
you know that's not how this works well
the difference is like you can settle
your stuff you know so if i if i if i'm
at the ufc bottom of the ice star squawk
and you go shut up yeah
we got and then there's gonna be a
solution where some loser could just
talk trash like a real good comic it
never gets settled yeah yeah yeah it
does get settled though in a way it does
get settled yeah over tickets nah just
in life i know because also on stage
that's a lie
as far as not really though you could do
it like let's say the three of us went
to laugh actually tonight and there's
some hate or comic there like all right
you go up and then we'll follow you
let's see that's who gets more laughs
yeah it's very black and white
uh the same as fighting
like punching a guy in the face well but
it's so it's all weird like there's guys
that are like they they're like oh like
i don't want to follow certain dudes
like
like malik at dude that dude murders
okay he's on the show that's malik s
this is not something
but he [ __ ] murders bro and and like
i'm always like bro i don't want to
follow that [ __ ] that guy
murders and then he sees me he's like i
don't want to follow you and it's like
fun it's a mutual respect yeah yeah yeah
but but if if he's on after me or if i'm
scheduled after him i'm not gonna not go
up it's like all right [ __ ] it i'm
either gonna go up and do well or or not
do well because he murdered and who
gives a [ __ ] but like there's comics
that are like they don't want to follow
you or they don't want to follow
somebody and they make it about
something else or like correct yeah i
should be going earlier or like this
crowd's going to be it's like dude you
just don't want to just say it yeah just
say you don't want to [ __ ] who gives a
[ __ ] yep
that's what i don't get because then it
becomes all this
this other thing where it's like what
are you really upset but everyone can
sense that they just don't say it you
know i know like everyone can sense so i
know but it's like it's like you don't
have a phone because you're not very
funny i know but then it's but then
everyone like
like you know kind of caters to their
excuses exactly they just throw it
around and they tiptoe around and then
they want to be like careful with their
egos and [ __ ] and it's just like that's
why that's why i won't i never
entertained this because i never
understood it to me it's such [ __ ] [ __ ]
whenever even one of our friends would
drop a special
we'd all go to the comedy store and writ
man you hear blah blah special not very
good man and i was like you know what
this is our boy dude yeah yeah
cannibalism it never made sense to me
even if it sucked i'd still be like yeah
i thought it was good you know bro but
it's i i could name on my hand how many
times i've heard him like do that
special crushed from like our crew i
know but also it was like also such this
weird mentality but also you know him
doing better doesn't take away from him
but you do have a lot easier for you and
as a matter of fact it makes it easier
for you dude the bigger comedy is the
bigger comedy is and you're a [ __ ]
comedian and here's the other thing too
is you you know
it's a live medium it's always best live
right you know for sure
like a special is always uh it's kind of
a watered-down version so if you enjoyed
the special live yeah it's gonna knock
your dick in the dirt i mean that's the
problem with all those netflix things
all this stuff is like people like my
mom are clicking on it and then going
like hey
he's not funny yeah i know you wouldn't
like right right right the problem is
it's too many you had a good point at
dinner last night it's like you know
let's say you release a special wherever
comedy central netflix uh youtube
youtube yeah whatever let's say release
on youtube a lot of guys are doing i
think that probably the move which we'll
get to later but um you release it on
there
you know you're in a safe space if it's
your home crowd right yeah you can say
whatever you want they know you're not a
bigot or a racist or whatever you're in
a safe space with your fan base you can
get away with whatever you want because
they if they listen to your podcast
they've seen you do stand up they know
you're a good person yeah it's like
talking about family yeah exactly and
you're in this like like any joke you
guys may you guys make to today or
tonight it's not going to offend me i
know you guys you're great people yeah
but then when you release on youtube or
netflix or comedy central when you get
people who don't know who you are who
tune in like oh my god this is offensive
it'd be like a television
i'd be like televising our dinner last
night yes oh yeah yeah people go
can't believe what he said he's like nah
man like you don't know right
you're peeking into a thing that we're
letting you peek into that isn't
especially when i went on that racist
tirade that i truly believed
i wasn't going to name names no
christians yeah but but that's that
that's where like a lot of races against
indians i don't know it's weird like
even chappelle with portuguese you name
it
but even chappelle with like his
transphobic stuff like that it's like
he's not trying to joke
yeah but it's like once you put that out
into the general area yeah it's gonna
offend some people man you know even
schultzy with his thing on netflix it's
like he offended you know a certain race
or whatever and it's like yeah dude but
his
his crowd which is fairly large yeah
they love that stuff man that's what he
does i just don't understand you can't
like seeing chapel dave chappelle like
and thinking like it's so obvious that
he's just like a guy who is trying to
think about things in all of the
different ways
and he seems like a really good guy like
it's so weird to just like
have you done shows with him
yeah i mean at the comedy store yeah
hung out in the green room he's a great
guy yeah actually he came to one of my
shows in uh a while ago and uh at comedy
works in denver he was just in the green
i'm like oh [ __ ] what's up i was like
you want to go up he was like nah just
chill
you just [ __ ] want to be around stand
up yeah he's a cool dude i mean he's
great dude what's he's doing he likes
everybody look at the [ __ ] with rogan
dude yeah it's like i know i mean do you
know rogan at all he's such a good
person like one of the best human beings
i've ever met in my life which is such
an influence on me and so when i see
what the media is doing with him and
they're like oh he's far right like the
simpsons made this joke that he's this
far-right canceled comic it's like if
that's cancelled sign yeah they did they
made that joke the simpsons
because homer gets cancelled yeah he's
like trying to go to all these
businesses and everyone's pushing away
and then he goes to rogue and it says
like far-right podcaster it's like a
billboard and rogan answers the door you
know it's not the real yeah it's the
cartoon but looks like rogan and whoever
did the voice it's not rogan right and
then uh rogan goes come on in homer even
goes i'm good and turns around
so it's like hey simpsons are you so out
of touch
like if if your creators went on rogue
you know how much that would help you
guys out yeah like you know he's
single-handedly the biggest in the world
yeah that's why and with this cancer
culture you've made them even so wow
those downloads have gone up
over two million per episode since they
tried to cancel him dude he's gotten
bigger because what happens is the sh
the the people that aren't sheep out
there they see the headlines like what's
this guy [ __ ] talking about let me
look into it yeah they click on it like
he's not far right he's pretty
open-minded oh man this is entertaining
yeah wow i kind of learned something and
so then they tell their friend and then
his downloads go bubba
yeah like you made them back in the
media so stupid so stupid like that dude
but it's hollywood's just so they're in
their bubble they're so out of touch i
know they're so hard to touch it's like
jimmy kimmel going at the elk boys
like making fun of the nut boys like oh
yeah trump on and this just shows you
trump would say the same thing to uh
politicians you well these frat boys
frat boys yeah much
dude that [ __ ] one now boy just goes
to the gas station he's like here's ten
thousand dollars here's ten thousand
dollars here's ten times dude when they
were dropping their seltzer when they're
dropping that you can hate them all you
want but they're doing something right i
don't know how many [ __ ] subscribers
they have 40 minutes
they're the new movie stars man correct
like the [ __ ]
you know logan paul this dude is a
[ __ ] w we would you want to be a [ __ ]
we want to be one of the [ __ ] fourth
actors on a csi show yeah like this and
they own it all you morons and then also
i know i know
it's just so [ __ ] nuts what was that
chin
exhaust for me oh okay i thought you
gave me a passcode but yeah it's so
funny man like but but it's almost like
jimmy kimmel is like in such a bubble
and he used to be so funny dude i used
to love jimmy yeah i used to be a savage
yeah when he's on the man show and he's
playing karma alone yeah where's that
jimmy you get hooked into the system and
then you can't it's who you are you
can't leave and like you got to play by
those rules man it's [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] but you think someone
going jimmy kimmel's literally like hey
man you know how like you average about
150 thousand views a night yeah the elk
boys will put up a video of them
drinking seltzer he gets like 20 million
yeah
like one of their videos it's like when
i look at when i look at [ __ ] like
this stupid [ __ ] show that amy
schumer's coming out with the [ __ ]
life and beth
it's like or whatever it is on hulu
and like hilarious to me and like what
she's doing yeah i know and then like
hollywood is like having her host the
oscars and it's like
this is not
2015
and like nobody's gonna watch this
[ __ ] [ __ ] but if hollywood patting
each other on the [ __ ] back that
nobody's watching and they're only
supporting each other but with amy
dude look at her come up like if you wat
like amy schumer was on you know uh
kevin and bean she was on uh opening
anthony savage yeah sucking dick
savage all the jokes that come in it oh
dude savage yeah it's like savage dude
super talented yeah and then now she got
really famous now it's you know all
women this
bro
she was like what got you to the dance
like dude she used to be so she was like
she was like uh yeah louis ck shouldn't
come back [ __ ] that she didn't it's like
bro what
what and she's like i know a lot of my
male comedian friends don't don't don't
like when i say that but [ __ ] them like
okay right you're on the you're on top
of your your tower there on the high
horse
black lives matter just said [ __ ]
jesse smallett is [ __ ] innocent dude
how hilarious is that the movement's
done dude ride the movement go ahead yep
yep let me know crazy man but again for
them in their bubble i know and all like
yeah you didn't like each other but the
majority of america was like you were
out man well i would say a lot of the
people that pretend to be in it aren't
either they're not they're not but they
have to they're not they're happy
they're all
you don't really believe all that
[ __ ] yeah and then they go
yeah yeah i gotta say it you know i lose
my job at hbo you know i gotta i gotta
pretend amy schumer's pretty yeah she
comes in here we gotta act like she's a
you know a ten we have to go baby what
do you want you know yeah that's the new
oh that's that because there's slightly
sleazy businesses yeah yeah oh yeah you
know what you're doing is really
beautiful here you know it's like
sarah silverman's like miss woke she
said the n word like four times on uh
jesus's magic special she had a black
face the second she had a comedy central
she's super talented too that's what
bums me out well i'm just saying like
the hypocrisy is what's annoying
i'm not mad at her for doing that either
she's a comedian so i got her back but
it's like
10 years that's my thing like 10 years
ago where was that same energy that the
what got you fans and your fame you've
completely 360 now and also she'll be
like well that's old i've grown since
then well so did shane gillis and so did
you like louisiana oh louis ck stuff or
like well we're not putting a time stamp
on any of that
you know i think sarah superman had
louie's back actually during that thing
so good on her but like i'm saying a lot
of the other gals didn't a lot of these
other female comics dude no no no yeah
ah back to fighting though donna
nelson's one of my favorites oh look at
this i hope he wins he's a badass dude
real badass
he's fighting my main man hooker right
or no no no no no
no no dude hooker's next i think oh no
patty's next which is this
see that yeah that's a patty wig yeah
when patty comes out this place can go
nuts was there any reason you couldn't
just wear pants
no you can't wear pants that'd be a bad
idea why
grab
because when you're sweaty you can get
us submissions they have pants on
there's no sweat ah and uh i'm not gonna
hurt all these chicks do the same thing
when the camera comes on they do the
yeah they look like kitty cats that's
cool right that's exactly right that's
cool right i think it's really cool man
all right so who do we want here the uh
we want gunnar nelson gunner okay
any reason
uh he's just a good dude
he's been out for a while he's been out
for a hot second he had an injury chin
you don't you don't ever vote for the
asian guys or anything well you just
look them up yeah i'm korean i said
asian i didn't say it yeah dude you want
to talk about racism
dude with asians
when they say stop asian hate they were
talking to asians stop hating
i was in asia for eight weeks and what
were you doing out there for that show
better late than never oh yeah and uh it
was funny like we were in the car and i
was on one of my soap boxes you know i
was going you know racism isn't
exclusive to white people it's a problem
all over the globe and our translator
just offered up she goes that's true we
hate koreans i was like jesus
she just admitted it like
she's on a work trip wow
but uh nelson seems like a good guy huh
yeah nelson he's a stud he's from or was
he from iceland
yeah i think so the guy on the right
yeah you know that's a guy that honestly
just look at his whole thing he has to
be bald there's no if he had hair it'd
be weird he'd look ridiculous yeah what
you talking about sato he looks good
yeah
jeff you have you don't have any issues
with your hair do you use uh no i'm
thinking about getting joel mckellen had
been talking about getting uh getting
just this part you know you got to be
careful with that though because you're
right now it might look good but bro
that if that stays like that when you're
like 65 that looks weird to not be a
little bit receding i think about 65
when i get 60. i know i know i know 65
how old are you 39 yeah no i don't know
i know but i'm 25 years old so what are
you gonna do shave that part no it's
gonna look ridiculous by then she'll be
stuck with me dude oh i see by then yeah
so it's about that okay yeah well no i'm
looking for a wife man well i was just
thinking like chicks well like when i
was in high school i used to that
murray's hair stuff it's like for black
guys it's like the thickest thing in the
world we get like a dollar can of it
last like 12 years and so i just kept
glopping this crap on and my friends
were like dude you keep doing that it's
going to affect your hair because it's
going to clog all those poi i go i don't
worry about that when i'm old and now
i'm old and so i'm worried about it and
when i'm 65 i'll have to worry about 65
year old problems would you ever do the
uh pivot thing and go with the the hair
piece listen i would i want callum to
get a toupee listen listen no
when my hair goes she called it the
pivot when my hair goes there's one
thing that you can do is get surgery and
get it so where it's going to look good
there's nothing else to do but that or
just go bald right you shave it
shave it or
or just you know yeah you're going to
[ __ ] wear a [ __ ] wig right in
modern times that's crazy yeah exactly
where is it i'll just how do your face
all white and make your cheeks rosy
bring a gavel around you [ __ ] weirdo
all right here he goes
uh nelson's a badass oh sato is done
yeah he doesn't want to be here but two
minutes you got some time to do some
work if you're gunner nelson
this is probably the most criticized
thing of the sport huh grappling when
they're in this little position he has
his back to the dominant position
and he's a very good grappler so the the
english crowd is going to be a little
more lenient than
american crowds get very frustrated if
you don't rip the guy's head yeah they
want like yeah like rip his head like a
dog when i was fighting man and i'd be
walking the cage and be like kill
nobody's killing anybody kill him you're
making it worse by saying that oh he's
old nice elbows
it's elbow knight
elbow night in england
he doesn't have a tattoo or nothing on
that elbow like balance he didn't want
to vet that too it's very rare wow so
relaxed i was just not gonna look at him
he looks like he could be reading a book
ding ding let's get you over here taking
his mouth out
chris's little brothers chris since
you've joined fight command you've never
watched more fighting in your life yeah
i don't not watch the fights though like
but yeah the big ones you'll get at home
right yeah i've spent my entire life
going i'm gonna get into this and i just
never get into it so this is good for me
do you enjoy it i love it awesome
i watch fake fighting of course i'm
gonna like real fighting you you watch
wwe yeah i like pro wrestling hold up
hold up you still watch wwe not really
we don't follow but we have like i have
a party at my house like once a month
for wrestlemania yeah like they have a
pay-per-view every month and we just
i'll get my buddies over there we'll
watch it it's silly we know it's dumb
yeah it's fun no just watching it it's
real
dude i i i i stopped watching when i was
12 when i found out macho man was
pretending and uh broke your heart
dude crush me wow that's funny and then
i you know westwood isn't real right
yeah i know but is it the same thing
it's acting it's all fake there
everyone's in on it but your kids would
like it
they watch real fighting like my kids
love you oh yeah yeah they call it my my
little boss goes boom boom pow wow like
we watched the weigh-ins and he was
doing like he's going like this are they
going to fight you think no absolutely
not you don't want them to know what
dude kids that grew up in calabasas
don't fight in the ufc
yeah
that's what yeah you gotta come from
screwed him out of that huh yeah we
don't want him do that that's daddy's
legs that's a tough go yeah i mean he
does jiu jitsu he loves jiu jitsu oh
there you go still a lot of yeah
what are you gonna do if calvin wants to
get [ __ ] what if calvin wants to be a
cage fighter dude can you send him my
way or what hilarious that would that be
yeah i'll just be like and handle this
please hey brandon can he live with you
all right i'll take another one he's so
[ __ ] cute i'll do it i know dude you
don't want him cage fighting no no of
course not
all the girls i know they don't even
want their kids playing football
yeah little cage
i don't want i don't want calvin to play
football you don't want to play football
because the ct thing it's just like
purses are you [ __ ] dad i'm a poor
[ __ ] dad no you [ __ ] dad nah i mean
just like [ __ ] you [ __ ] dad i'm a
[ __ ] dad yeah that's fine but just like
play hot [ __ ] baseball you know take
breaks do normal stuff take breaks no ct
yeah take breaks it'd be great for kids
just to baller at golf or some [ __ ] so
you don't have to worry about it yeah
yeah yeah yeah the problem is something
like that my kids are giants no risks
for sure they can get recruited by the
football coach you know that's how it
goes
but and also
in general dude you look at the stats
ct don't be such a baby dude i don't
know the stats i just you know i saw
that movie the majority nothing i don't
want my son
being that a movie a movie made about
what will smith plays you got you got
that
i think i had a stroke right
[Laughter]
you could be the stroke comic on agt
you'll win for sure yeah no doubt
you look at this think how many people
play football think about how many
[ __ ] kids play football and think i
may actually have ct is that a normal uh
posture for fighting this guy no it's a
very karate stance okay very wonder boy
very very crowded
light on the toes movement wide stance
does he do karate
his bathroom is karate really yup
wow
usually karate is frowned upon yeah i
know because you can get your blackberry
on the year it's the easiest uh
discipline to get your black belt in
jeff do you have a black belt on
anything no but i'll tell you you know
they do those uh i want to thought about
learning karate you thought about
learning crowd we went down there and
it's all a bunch of kids you know they
don't yeah it's like crazy you've seen
that seinfeld episode with kramer no i
did great though i was throwing these
[ __ ] around
i was like nobody beats a giant first
day just crushing that's the seinfeld
episode he's talking uh trash i was
dominating and he's like man i signed up
for karate man i'm just dominating
they're giving my black belt and so
jerry and uh them are like well i might
as well check him out he goes down and
he's with all kids
that's great just beating the [ __ ]
that's
my dad got really into [ __ ] oh great now
your comments are gonna go jeff dies
stole his signs
what a piece of [ __ ] 1996. why is this
new guy here doesn't know fighting my
dad got really into taekwondo i had to
go watch him with his black belt and
he's like breaking boards and [ __ ] oh
yeah yeah those boards never fight back
do they yeah dude
he loved it
and those taekwondo things still those
old school thing my dad's like the
problem is we can't spar we kill each
other well that's not true is it that
far have you ever told the story on your
podcast that you told us last night
about the traffic thing
which one that you and your old my dad
my dad fighting yeah no it's a great
story yeah it's hilarious
the shop household getting a fight on a
freeway it reminds me because it was
clearly my birthday anniversary of my
birthday my dad got in a street fight i
was like ten
and expect and your brother got in on an
action jay has some anger issues you
wouldn't think that right even as a kid
yeah he's so sweet you had to go to
anger management as kids does he still
have anger stuff he had to flare up
every now and then really yep it'll
flare up oh i'd love to see him oh dude
i don't think i've ever seen him not
smiling i know we call him shark eyes
doll smile that's the angriest guy
though the smiley leg you're like you're
not that happy all the time here's that
jeffrey dahmer thing about him you know
you gotta be careful around him no he'll
just go zero to 100 like this it's just
dude
is it always like rational things that
take him off no no no no that makes me
afraid he'll fight you over the night
could be 1996 chicago bulls i like that
that's the kind of angry i like yeah i
don't want if you're like actually angry
for like it's like
i love people get angry over the dumbest
[ __ ] like angry so funny
it's hilarious it is funny yeah but i'm
not punching anyone yeah does he do that
to him
yeah but yeah he used to beat me up all
the time that's what i'm dangerous no i
meant like let's say me and him are just
kicking it wow if he laid you out oh my
god that would be [ __ ] he's just he's
a
he's just a liability my manager's alive
he's my
tour manager he made some crack about a
thing i didn't like it and they go i
thought we were that that was our thing
sucked him in the face
oh here we go he's got him in the old
frog
yeah i don't know where his hand came
he got made fun of a lot as a kid
because of glasses and braces oh and he
had all black friends my brother oh so
he was like the white boy but he's
really tough so he had to fight to prove
himself it's kind of
the white dude seems to be dominating
this fight yes he's definitely winning
this fight it'd be great if he could
submit him so we can look at that little
punk shot
the body triangle and so what he's doing
there with the body triangle he's
controlling his breathing so it makes it
very difficult to breathe
but yeah he's gonna ride him forever
because if he doesn't break that leg
triangle
oh boy you gotta be the problem is you
can't transition like an arm
arm bar or anything like that sit on a
burr but whatever very underrated the
breathing
oh you do a lot of yoga right jeff yeah
i love yoga really yeah because i drink
so much it's like nice to sweat it all
out yeah but you're not dude
i thought you were the one friend i had
because brian drinks wine like a [ __ ]
old man the one friend i thought who
would drink whiskey with me well i today
i i promise you i will any uh today i'll
die
you think you'll die i've died dude if
you take whiskey you just saw what my
last five days at home wasn't like oh
yeah this guy shouldn't even be here
right now yeah it's been brutal
we think you got the old uh coven no
it's definitely not covered no it's like
an internal uh like an infection in my
stomach
from drinking from drinking i think it's
uh you think it's from drinking
vegetables oh wow jesus
had some fun in nashville you know oh
god
you did have fun in nashville we had a
good time yeah it's great jelly roll
tried to kill us too man i [ __ ] sent
him a bill warned you guys man that guy
is great yeah he's the best and hopeful
why about from drinking he just forces
like we went to this soho house in
nashville and he comes with a [ __ ]
plate of 40 shots i'm like jelly there's
three of us
also in the green room he was like he so
i've i've
you know been in this business long
enough i've seen every approach in a
green room yeah the way people come in
the way people sneak in the way people
go you know this dude walked into the
green room he had went to the grocery
store the liquor store and he's brought
his own alcohol wow
huge bottles of vodka no he drinks
tequila and he was tequila and then he
brought tennessee whiskey for me yeah he
goes this for you he goes you drink this
mom i have tequila i go jelly do you
really think she'll be drinking and he
goes do i talk to my doctor and he said
i can drink but only tequila i would
find a new doctor joe that's a terrible
yes i feel like wait
because he's like 400 pounds yeah yeah
his doctor is a guy named boston who's
also a security guard
that's right so
this security guard was so that guy's
awesome
yeah
we have some killers i'm like
oh i don't i don't need killers yeah i
don't know but we're also what lifestyle
you think i'm living yeah we're also
hiring him yeah
wow dude he's a big artist huh jelly's
huge yeah some of his videos have damn
near a billion views right what yeah
like hundreds of millions maybe even wow
he's the nicest guy ever too he's a
great guy he's so talented i'm helping
him do his podcast oh cool
i wish this fight would end there's been
all finishes till this point
well at this point sato has to knock him
out to win right there you go jeff
you're right he's down this is good how
many rounds is this three okay so
there's the last one yeah yeah
but the main one's five
uh main ones five but it's heavyweight
so it's but volkov will go to decision
but aspinall if he wins it won't go to
decision if he goes to decision that
means aspen all lost the fight they're
really good at plugging this stuff like
i don't never even heard of that patty
kid till this morning i'm on i'm very
excited for it it should be
listen as far as like marketing goes
hype there's there's no organization nba
nfl mlb better than ufc as far as a
marketing machine they're the best in
the business and they took a you'd
appreciate this they took a slice from
the wwe like they mimicked the wwe's
plan you know the wb has like a
subscription plan yeah in their
marketing ufc did the exact same thing
ufc fight pass yeah there's a heel
there's you know kobe coming to the heel
they market it really well that's smart
yeah because wrestling's always they
they've learned from trial and error
over the years with that oh vince
mcmahon vince mcmahon is like modern-day
pt barnum yeah he's smart with all that
stuff
when he said pt uh barnum uh is the
circus still going on or no but it's
like he's like that man he runs this
little weird dysfunctional circus which
is wrestling
have you talked to wrestlers yeah i have
a good friend who was the wwe diva
champion and she was like it's a tough
go man we're on the road 300 days a year
we're booking our own flights yeah
they're just riding each other and
rental cars after business not like
glamorous yes you're like stone cold
steve austin yeah but even he had to do
that forever
it's like comics you know it's way was
well i'm just saying as far as you're on
the road all the time you're not really
making money until you're like
headlining you're staying [ __ ] hotels i
did a girl like the number one selling
t-shirt in like wrestling history and i
think she got like you know this five
percent or something like that you think
should be they own everything yeah it's
called the other contracts they can't
even do like an autograph signing no he
gets all of the money vince does yeah i
don't know if any of that's changed
since i don't want anybody like getting
mad at me but like but you know what the
guy is
blind you know why the rock doesn't use
the rock in like uh movies movies
he doesn't own it yeah everything's
dwayne johnson vince mcmahon still owns
if it's if they say the rock vince
mcmahon goes cha-ching wow wasn't that
crazy
yeah
yeah
look at this guy sato is not even
blocking him keeps doing this dude it's
like and he always doing he's holding
his arm
yeah so he can't get him he's getting
his [ __ ] but his [ __ ] submission
defense is pretty lit
yeah
the problem with the body lock gentlemen
is he can't like you you're not going to
transition the arm bar or mount your
body you're just going to stay on the
back right right right you know this
chris you're going to do yeah i do know
that you guys wearing them like a belt
they'd say a backpack
backpack is what they say yep
i get it because you know he like is on
and it's strapped in
there's a belt there too though books in
his [ __ ]
keep books in my box oh now he's really
bleeding out there oh
jeff
that would be cool to be a fighter and
your name is the backpack dude i like
that and then after you when you run
home pretty hard
like a jansport backpack gun
every time is running back on he just
wants to get home
it's like a therapy session i would just
run home yeah dude if i wanted to get up
here i'd
mail me my [ __ ] no interview oh he might
get there almost there yeah now you opt
out of that interview afterwards
uh you don't want to that's your time to
shine and call the fighters out yeah but
if you market yourself as guys dude this
is this guy who just [ __ ] he runs
home dude he didn't even put his shoes
on
that wouldn't he's got a jansport tattoo
on his back on the back but no you run
home uber bloody yeah no shirt but you
run home and then you call out your you
do your post fights yeah that's from
your bed and they go good night yeah
turn the tv off be sick all right here
we go
what's sato's first name
i guess it won't matter about 10 seconds
it's not going to matter your boy uh
patty's coming up next on this crowd's
going to go nuts three more fights left
volume three more
and the next three fights are bangers
yeah that's the best wait what uh how
come you can't listen because obviously
people ufc does this weird thing we're
gonna have rights there the fight so the
yeah let's shut the stream down
although you'd think it'd be good
marketing for them you know
yeah but you want people stealing [ __ ]
yeah you're related
i mean i guess you're in the game you're
in the clique oh what's going on from jk
rowling what's going on here lord of the
rings hell yeah my parents said i can't
watch this because it's you know
witchcraft and stuff right
my parents said that uh for dungeons and
dragons when i was a kid when jk rowling
wants to make a jesus movie we'll watch
that at the house
that was the movie johnny depp was
supposed to be in they canceled him out
of it
was that because the amber heard [ __ ] i
love it how [ __ ] jk rowling has did
stuff and she was like saying so much
like
anti-trans stuff and and hollywood's
like no that's not right and they're
like okay but she makes so much money
let's make more movies yeah
that's the secret i know you gotta be
yeah
you gotta be the top
yeah she's a savage huh and then all her
actors have to like be like oh we don't
support her
but okay we'll do the movie okay we'll
be the next [ __ ] troll in her movie i
wouldn't care about any of that stuff
if i was in hollywood who cares
partaking any of it
you know your boss is like a terrible
guy i don't know
yeah also
also i came since when are bosses
not pieces of [ __ ] yeah there's always
you know what i mean like when they got
mad at ellen it's like she's the boss
yeah it's hard to work for the boss
because bosses are [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
that's why they're that type of [ __ ]
like when i came to l.a someone had this
great joke of her who it was it was a
tweet i think but it's so true when i
first came to l.a like 10 12 years ago
they go you're you're gonna learn two
things that i like when you first get
here you're gonna get a parking ticket
and you hear a terrible story about
ellen degeneres that's pretty funny yeah
so funny it's true it's so true yeah and
it's spot-on but i'll tell you what's
spot-on
i'll tell you what's spot-on
i think ellen's using kratom because
she's a smart gal oh really also used to
be a very funny comedian uh before she
turned an [ __ ] uh listen i use kratom
to fire up my brain before any shows
podcasts whatever it is it's my
limitless pill it's the best focused
product ever and it's probably got a lot
of chemicals though right oh chris dude
it's all natural it is we're talking
about happy hippo how about you read it
so i don't mispronounce okay visit happy
happyhippos.com and use promo code thick
boy that's three c's in there for 20 off
for life use that code as many times as
you want happyhippo herbals.com promo
code thick boy 20 off come on get up i'm
gonna take one right now there you go
ellen takes him
no i will say i actually got ellen's
back if i'm gonna be honest how so she
didn't do any crimes
i don't even know i honestly didn't do
anything all i know is there was an
upper i have no idea i didn't look she's
being a butthole she was just an [ __ ]
for so long i think it caught up to her
but you know what the problem so what no
you know what the problem is here's the
problem what i'm saying i get boss i i
don't think she should be canceled i
don't know
i got her back it's a daytime talk show
i don't give a [ __ ] i hurt anybody but
her thing is right
sure her act is happy helping people
i dance all the time she does help a lot
of people yeah but it's like this act of
like i'm so generous and so much fun and
then behind closed doors she's just this
[ __ ]
i've never had any yeah i i got her back
but she's just completely she goes
you're a camera guy get the [ __ ] out of
my face i wouldn't do that it's pretty
mean but like she can she's in charge
yeah
i don't know no i wouldn't you don't
think she should be cool
she can do whatever she wants but here's
the other but no why cancel her what i
don't get and maybe she got cancelled
she's just people stopped watching her
[ __ ] no they just had to laugh
and stuff and they were the last episode
was last week yeah this is amazing isn't
it nice shout out to ray
um is it rain energy drink
we have a
straight up vending machine back there
it's so hard as me to not just make fun
of everything so that i was about to
like
you know just the people you like
sponsor you know yeah rain's my boys
yeah i'm not gonna say anything thanks
buddy put on my mind i was about to say
and then i go what am i talking about
that's like
it's just in me unbelievable how that
tastes good huh dude they didn't send it
hey ray please send this yes dude
right it tastes like strawberry soda
bloats in your brain
daddy likes daddy likes that you're work
doing this but the the best is they have
one called carnival candy
it's in and there's no sugar in all any
there's no sugar in any of them you got
one of those hungry hippos or whatever
it is but here's yeah
i only hungry
whatever they call happy hair
that hip will be such a better day
i only drink i only drink water club
soda and coffee
i don't know if i've had a sip of
anything else in years
so that might be part of it but this is
also it's nice unbelievable
that's why i work with them dude all i
drink is coffee
and water no
all you drink is coffee bean and water
yeah yeah dude how i you and i drink
more coffee we were trying to debate
last night who drinks more coffee
i have more espresso shots throughout
the day for sure oh my god i'm on 12.
you're doing more shots in that cup than
most people do yeah in a week no doubt
what else i'm gonna have a heart attack
no you won't don't say that no they put
some i usually well meatball didn't are
these the happy hips
meatball dude uh yeah that's happy hippo
try that dude come to chinatown
uh what was that talking about oh but
meatball [ __ ] it up i usually just do
black espresso [ __ ] he put [ __ ] in
here you know it's meatball bro i was so
clear with him
yeah i said put some cream in this
double shot of espresso and the guy
looked at me like i had my dick in my
hand
you did
well that was but you still we weren't
recording
yeah meatball might be autistic
the staffs laughing too i'm just kidding
i'm just kidding meatball
he's our peanut butter falcon you know i
love him and i'm shyla buff i'm just
trying to get him to the wrestling match
you know
i try to remember what happened earlier
today he squared me up a little bit
meatball did yeah he's a feisty like him
dude i think he's play hockey i think
he's yeah well for sure i also think he
has so much rage in him because he's so
short yeah
you know he is like that short no i
think that's what it was i think he was
trying to figure out how tall i really
am but he kind of squared me up a little
bit like oh good i feel like is it
happening do you have the same problem
that my boy mark harley has
he's so distractingly good looking like
his hair his face like you said it looks
like you made it with a [ __ ] anaconda
like his skin's weird right like he's
here right he's here he's here
no mark's back there yeah
no mark no ma mark looks like uh mark
mark looks like he looks like his
[ __ ] dad was macho man randy savage
like they both have that leather scandal
like they both have like that weird
leather skin
dad was macho man randy savage and his
mom was macho man randy savage
mark harley looks [ __ ] particular no
king nacho had sex with a brand new good
looking dude
he's a unique looking dude so he goes on
the road with me right all the time
when we walk the streets
there's no
in between yeah it's either people are
[ __ ] drooling or they want to stab
him in the hole
i think you should shave his head that's
what looking like i would say you're a
very conventional looking guy the the
thing like the guy with the golf club
the other day like you almost got to
fight because the way he looks
yeah no you trigger me i want to talk
about it you trigger me yeah you're like
it's just look it is
he looks like the witcher he looks yeah
no he looks like his like his mom was
macho man randy savage his dad was the
undertaker yeah like it's this weird
combo is he married or got a lady
mark you want to answer that
we don't have to you're talking no mark
looks like blanca
looks like blanca i'll just say i gotta
ask like so like i wanna look like that
you know moy's like dude if i just
jagged arms and and then girls i don't
know if they're just like trying to make
me feel better or something
oh that's what it is hey mark i'm just
spitballing ideas here have you ever
thought of only fans for guys
how much money you would make with that
big stupid dick of yours hundreds of
dollars even his dick has like abs on
the side of it wow yeah no but i always
think like girls will be like we don't
like guys they got big arms like that
but i think they're just telling me that
because i don't have big arms they're
trying to make no i said this i said
this on rogan before i feel like guys
get really big just for other guys yeah
well i think because girls are like it's
too much man it's like when you were in
high school i used to peel out with my
truck or just like a burn rubber and
then i thought it was so cool yeah
that's only for other guys yeah but all
the girls be like we hate that guy jeff
you know he burns
out yeah but i thought it was the
coolest [ __ ] in the world like when i
bench went up whatever 400 pounds girls
aren't like oh my god that's right it's
dude the boys do yeah it's the boy for
the bros man [ __ ] yeah look at this
chick still dancing around we get it
meat wad you won
she's really making a meal of this isn't
she
it's in her hometown dude she's in the
stands
knockout with spitting elbow meat
what's going on here she's eating nachos
with all the fans going oh yeah he's
singing songs be great she just had a
ton of meatballs yeah well i can't
believe that [ __ ] drink awesome it's
great and it [ __ ] great
hey quite a minute oh here he comes i
guarantee it's our best
you got a headset i can just so you guys
know yeah jeff should be able to listen
to this just so you guys know he could
sell this thing out on his own before
he's at the ufc that's how big of a deal
let me ask you a question he's our
justin bieber yes why we all know what
he what everyone wants him to be right
what we're hoping he is and what ufc
really hopes he is
if he gets knocked out it's over first
round over it's over for all of it
yeah all the hype goes away okay really
fighting dude
fighting is is that kind of even
really if he got starched like right out
the gate like because he's it's like a
rocket taking off yeah and then if that
thing just doesn't take off we're on all
right [ __ ] that right interesting bro
yeah [ __ ] that rocket but also the ufc's
it's different than boxing's boxing you
lose they're like oh [ __ ] that guy the
ufc like think about our stars it's like
nate diaz uh nick diaz jorge mazvidal
they're the five of the biggest
those three are in the top five biggest
stars they have a ton of losses conor
mcgregor doesn't want to fight in a
[ __ ] hot second yeah the mma fans
realize that the sport is so hard
there's so many ways to lose you can
lose when you get to a certain point in
the ufc in boxing if you lose you're out
dude yeah
like so
this is second fight
he has the most hype behind him since
conor mcgregor because conor mcgregor
was big before he came to the ufc by the
time he came he had a [ __ ] nation
behind him this kid is very similar
maybe he's he has the skill set maybe
he's already done this but if i'm conor
mcgregor i just take this dude under my
wing yeah yeah yeah yeah i make it our
team like uh this is that would be
really smart for connor yeah yeah or
what's it matter should i do that alpha
crap where you're like i'm still i could
still fight the young lad it's like no i
would make him my guy
i'd be ringside with him going this is
this is past that torch
he's fighting a mexican dude that's what
tiger's gonna look like how he's got
chest here you can't grow a beard that's
what tiger's gonna look like and that's
what calvin's gonna look like on the
left
yeah this is tiger versus calvin the
tiger
no shade no shade on kazula but
hopefully he has better skills you know
it's like he's a brawler he's a tough
customer obviously world-class athlete
tiger will be way bigger
let me in the office
he's five eight tigers five eight right
now i left my
backpack
i mean ty
tiger is going to be five eight in
eighth grade and and oh easy yeah yeah
yeah usually yeah they won't get the
reference have you done that
have you have you done that with the
doctor where they they give you like the
they're like the kid we know for sure is
gonna be yeah
cause your wife is tall and you're tall
oh he's in now he's in game mode i like
this kid yep he was having fun
but now he's like
you know the hype on like uh let me
think of like uh like a patrick mahomes
like his second year sure that's what
this is our version patrick mahomes dude
so just so you know so like you know
so yeah so minus 675 for ufc fight is
not so stupid because anything can
happen right minus 160 175 is nuts you
know what's funny is that after you
explained how how cutthroat your
business is if he wins or loses i'll be
pretty happy
no you want him to win i know but like
that's pretty to watch a thing then i
gotta go to the bathroom
hopefully but uh yeah i gotta if i had
to if i had to bet on this he's gonna
finish this in the first round yeah he's
going to knock this guy out in the first
round
yeah i got to pee i'm going to pee hard
yeah me too i got a pee that's it yeah
you got to pee hard i've been peeing out
of my butt all week yeah i got a well i
drank four coffees and i don't know [ __ ]
oh there you go i think i didn't want to
give it a five but he did oh
[ __ ] talented dude the problem is
though because of fighting but patty's
seen it before this guy hits hard dude
he got tagged
oh [ __ ] he got attacked
the other thing about the ufc is like
there's nothing better when we have a
young prospect with a lot of hype
watching his come up like conor
mcgregor's come up or izzy out of
sanji's come up was so [ __ ] fun
francis and gano's come up it's there's
nothing better dude everyone might hate
me saying this but what i liked about
conor mcgregor is he'd always like say
like motivational stuff that i liked no
that's fair i like super motivational he
would say such cool yeah that's great
like oh he's so original dude yeah he'd
be like
i can't remember he's
you'll all know my name and he's like
young and i was like yeah right we're
not going to know that guy and he
[ __ ] did it i don't know why did he
do it but he changed the game forever
too because then he got into proper
whiskey and sold up
i was like this guy's dope but how did
he make 400 million already on that it
was for whiskey yeah because it got
so big so fast some big companies like
oh we see the potential and also you're
right i don't know whiskey company it's
all about distribution so he had such
mass distribution because of his name
they got in everywhere some big dog came
up because so many big dog alcohol
alcohol companies they went oh we'll
take it from here wow you know he got
400 million he sold his shares sold his
shares so a ton of money you know he
changed the game man he changed the game
now what's interesting is you know once
you have yeah he probably has more than
that let's say a 600 million in the bank
it's tough to fight dudes in a steel
cage in your underwear when you have 600
million in the bank [ __ ] that but he
still does it dude i had fifty thousand
dollars in the bank and went see ya yeah
you know yeah
[ __ ] that now he had 600 million his
last fight against him boy he pulled up
i think he was in abu dhabi or wherever
he pulled up on his own yacht dude in
gucci [ __ ] like pajamas i want to do
comedy for saudi princes yeah and trump
trust them just for three years i want
to have one
fan that is just a billionaire and he
pays me so much money dude
they'll be like yeah now make fun of the
peruvians you're like yeah [ __ ] the
peruvians you just whatever you like
everyone die whatever or not okay yeah
whatever here we go and we're smoking
hookah that's good chris go to your
quarters and uh we'll see you tomorrow
so what you want to be jeff is they call
uh the girls that do that like i used to
date when i first got delayed i had this
uh girl i was dating she was like oh i
got to go to saudi arabia for a month
and i was like god what's inside right
now
dude no well i didn't know at the time
was so innocent and she's a different
kind of hooker dude it is they call them
toilet girls i don't know this well
that's not totally worse
yeah dude so she goes to saudi arabia
she's there for a month and she goes oh
i'm part of this cell phone business huh
and my head went oh that makes sense
well he actually threw him yeah he's a
monster that never happens
and then she posted pictures just her by
herself on a yacht and private jet i
went wow this cell phone is really
paying you're hooking uh yeah she was
hooking i don't like when they pretend
they're not hooking just be like hey
over here hooking
hey gotta go to [ __ ] saudi arabia
well phil is just you know what i'm
gonna choke this guy out by the way
because he he's actually better at
grappling than he is striking he's good
at both but he's a phenomenal grappler
uh-oh here we go
now he promised he wouldn't get out of
the first round so he's really going to
try and finish this
oh he got it got it
game set match snake look at him wow
he's not even fighting a little british
snakey
he's not even fighting well but he's too
sideways right now yeah
it's in there what do you mean two sides
he's gotta get oh he got it now now
here's the thing that'll break your jaw
oh it's over it's over fellas he's going
to say it's over oh no first round
patty look at him
dance like that hey well that's what
makes him waving his wiener get some
legs that's what makes sense
oh god she's still out there they're on
the same team though you know jeff
yeah but she was in the other match up
there
she's cheers and jeff still can't get
over females or fighting
it's out of order so this kid is just
he's the next big star man wow now the
thing is you know you still gotta you
know feed them guys at his level like
you don't want to toss them in the top
10 at 55.
the division he's in is filled with
monsters first it's the most competitive
difference oh great and there's meat
water oh meatwad
so what's that so
oh she oh look at her yeah yeah
she was in the match
dude so okay so he
is
you're saying
uh his division is tough the toughest so
it's stacked so then
maybe he's not the best
not right now we're hoping he gets there
but at 55 you have a chance
what is that 155 155 155 pounds so you
have charles oliveira's your champ you
have justin gaichi fighting for the belt
oh these dudes oh yeah michael chandler
oh yeah dustin poirier oh really
just retired from there it's stacked oh
wow stack
my favorite fighter in the world you
have a guy named
makachev's a [ __ ] dagger standing
monster so like him versus makuchev
would be a nightmare right now but you
got to hope eventually he gets there
meaning keep working keep getting better
keep getting stronger got it right now
he's like featuring for a headliner he's
not headliner yeah you don't wanna put
him at the headlight yet
and his thing is and he's smart about it
same with sugar shawn he goes i'll fight
tougher guys we gotta pay me to fight
him like right now i'm on the pay scale
where i should be fighting these top
guys so he's like if you want me to
fight these guys pay me which is smart
this haircut's interesting huh
i like the haircut it looks like a wig
so michael bisping is the biggest uh uk
fighter ever yeah so they're hoping for
the next michael bisping
wow
well that was i predicted that one right
yep me too
so far undefeated
675
you go first well it's gonna be weird if
we just leave jeff by himself that'd be
amazing you go first uh go ahead okay go
ahead
a lot of brown today huh well speaking
of a lot of brown winning
oh yeah
oh because
because of the energy drink what
happened
all just all the coffees in the energy
yeah go make it rain dude
yeah you called your first fight right
dude but it might nailed it minus six
sentences what was the favorite
mean it's the way to do it yeah it's
like picking the rams the super bowl
yeah it's like picking rocky yeah
uh i didn't pick the rams in the super
bowl though but got that right yeah you
bet on it no i didn't get out of your
mind i was in vegas and i was gonna put
300 on the bengals and we'll put uh like
200 on joe burrow winning the mvp
all in on the whole game it looked like
that was going to happen no
it i i thought that game would blow out
odb didn't get hurt they were going to
blow them out i agree but there's more
money to win by betting on cincinnati
for sure and also i'm a seahawks fan and
the la rams are like the divisional
rivals so i was like rooting against
them even though half my friends are
like seahawks probably gonna get uh
baker mayfield huh you think so yeah i
think so god i'll be so mad i wouldn't
be dude he was a baller for he hurt his
shoulder you look at his stats before he
hurt his shoulder he's [ __ ] balling
for cleveland what a weird looking kid
huh
he's unique looking yeah he's very
strange looking
i think that's part so is conor though
right like these unique looking
characters like i don't hate it or
nothing it's just a weird look it just
doesn't look like you've never seen
anybody look like yeah yeah
big schnoz on this thing's watch is
distractingly awesome yeah that guy's
great he's your friend what's up that
guy what'd you say he's your friend
bisping yeah that's my boy
what's he saying here
i wish i could hear him we can't play
the uh we can't play the audio you can't
put the captions on there nope so we got
time to fill but april 9th
the thick mudder is going down for all
you thickies out there we got the thick
mudder april knight san bernardino it's
uh right outside there um come join the
thick boy squad it's at 10 30 a.m for
those of you that are terrified of the
15k i get it man i'm running the 15k
with the boys the thick boys but we also
offer a 5k if you use promo code sickboy
you get 10 off the signup fee
the whole squad will be there you got
mark harley there jeff is gonna run it
you have so much [ __ ] going on are you
going i'd do it but i can't do april 9th
oh yeah i'll do it on the road
yeah i got some more coming up i'm in
dude all right but uh so jeff won't be
there but the rest of the thick boys
staff will be there uh come run with me
and mark harley at 10 30 a.m april 9th
right outside la it's
probably one of their best tracks for
sure as far as mud and all that [ __ ]
come get electrocuted with us come have
a great time don't worry about being in
shape it's more of the uh just bonding
it's a great time man ask anybody who
ran with me last time it's uh april 9th
go sign up at toughmotor.com it's under
the thick boy sign up you see a picture
of my dumb ass it's at 10 30 a.m we got
the 15k and 5k promo code thick boy all
right and then uh
let's toss to the hype video chin we got
a little hype video for you guys enjoy
this lebron's why they call you the fire
boy cause everything that i do fire boy
i was the one with the can of the gas
and the matches the propane the tank and
the lighter boy
i was the one with the vision yeah now
they all look at me different now i'm
the one out here making decisions
looking around i don't see competition i
just started going in but i don't wanna
hurt the feelings all these thoughts up
in my head they run the minion as a
minute if i say that i'ma do it then i
really manifested if you said that you
gonna do a thing you probably never did
it i've been working every day and i've
been staying independent and i'm trying
to my business but the flow is
unattended and the pen is getting sick
from all the venom i've been dipping and
this [ __ ] is hitting different and it
happened it is
[Music]
no manager just got a gift like that boy
in the main edge oops i'm in manger the
game is in danger my peers are in danger
man read them appreciate it back and
forth sign up for uh thick boy and the
the thick mudder uh at toughmudder.com
april 9th
at thickboy.com we got the thick mudder
shirts if you order it right now you'll
get in time before the big race april
9th go to
thickboy.com right now get your thick uh
mudder shirt we'll all be rocking it
we're gonna look like a goddamn tsunami
out there man we also dropped the new
thick boy merch as well at thinkboy.com
the black shirt you see me wearing the
the dark blue shirt and the green
hoodies go get them right now at
nah but thickboy.com be in phoenix from
april 4 30.
i would love to see chris run the thick
mudder yeah you ever run one of those no
thick mudders no
it's kind of fun though you know you're
gonna warm that up chris no you get all
muddy
how old is it from like last time no no
mike mike
hey mike did you do you you cook this
[ __ ] yourself
does it matter just pick it up
where do you pick it up
a
from
outfit cooks it every saturday it's
called handy market that's good as [ __ ]
is it a white guy no hello then i'll try
it
yeah i went to that handy market they
didn't have anything for me
you got to change that sign you know
you didn't tell me what race though mike
i think mexican barbecue
okay i'll try it
is it nice i think we had it for uh josh
brunette on the last uh fighting pace
it's really good
the ribs are so nice you got the
barbecue sauce too over there all right
you don't like ribs oh you're a social
bath yeah i got barbecue sauce
nah i'm not gonna eat on air
professional i gotta take a
piss so hard why not i get a piece so
hard oh hey what's next before you go
take a piss more ladies uh april 9th we
also have the fight companion delia that
night so i'm gonna run that day be
covered in mud come straight in here
with you and brian
irvine are you
yeah god i want to do those shows with
you i'll i'll do that's a saturday i'll
do the show on friday
yeah
arnold allen and dan hooker next
great fight
hooker
that's disrespectful to not eat on air
you got to be you
your audience will respect you if you're
you i've never eaten on air maybe on a
rogue i've eaten down there i've never
eaten on air professional dude no it's
not dude have you ever seen
larry king eat on here no
johnny carson you've see you've seen jay
leno you down here you ever see jay leno
you're not here no but if he did i would
i mean my god
oh my god
the game changes bro there never used to
be a podcast i eat on air yeah that's
true
i see jay leno every sunday at uh cars
and coffees
and someone goes uh his boy uh spike
goes you know we're all porsche guys and
he goes hey man he's a comedy story he's
the comic store all the time and jay
goes oh yeah yeah yeah yeah he goes you
know i'm wearing a t-shirt he goes yeah
uh you know he's old he was you uh
you're on stage with all the tattoos and
stuff oh wow wow that's funny yeah it's
not
1978 but funny yeah really no super
self-conscious that's just comedy advice
yeah good comedy is about yourself oh
that's funny i saw cuss jay yeah yeah
yeah i'm the [ __ ] out of here i come up
with jokes from my brain and i tell them
and people laugh
yeah but even with the art on your arm
uh yeah well i'll see you later
it's a weird thing to worry about jake
but when a big dog tells you that you're
like all right yeah means nothing he was
great to my kids though he had this
ridiculous car and he let boston put his
[ __ ] sticky fingers all over the
window really steering wheel he's great
he's awesome he's a real gearhead he
knows his [ __ ] man
i'm gonna pee you guys hold the fort
down i got it i'll just keep talking
about this rain energy drink jeff you
can go too i got this solo podcaster
congratulations
[Laughter]
ah thank god he's gone dude
all this fight talk it's exhausting i
like how we leave so wait who's next
who's next oh
dan parker i got dan hooker yeah i've
voted for dan hooker i voted
um
yeah dude i don't know
he's the older guy like you said he's
the older guy arnold allen's like the
younger yeah dan hooker i've heard his
name for a bit
i just don't know much about this
fighting but i will say i do watch it
all the time but i honestly don't know
like it takes such a lot
it takes a long time for me to know
someone's name and like to see who the
[ __ ] like dude there's people that i see
at the laugh factory and i see them so
much and i just don't know their names
right do you are you good with them well
i'm good with names but like for
instance like i think like at the laugh
factory there'll be like servers and
stuff that i said i don't know any of
them i don't know any of that i know and
those people like are so
like the servers that
the the servers of the laughing are all
[ __ ] so great yeah but they're like
give me like hugs and that's it you know
like i don't know i was like oh
also during covid like i did like
everyone's i met people with masks on
and like i'm just starting to see their
face i don't think i ever got their name
yeah yeah yeah that is there's that
they're just like hey jeff's here and
like i get my hug like i was gone like i
could tell you 10 things about their
life but i don't know their names right
names too the improv has really i
[ __ ] the staff at the improv is
awesome
um
i know their names because they've been
around forever yeah they're a lot of
effective
change in them
um mostly because of jamie jimmy's
changing everything always
but um
yeah so so when i'm like watching these
fights
like that paddy guy because he's so
[ __ ] memorable and he seems like a
patty and he's jumping around i'll
remember him but like i already forgot
the other guy he his name kazula because
well that's [ __ ] kind of a he's like
yeah he's like one and two before he
fought paddy they're they're they're
making patty come up like you know yeah
the way boxing yeah yeah yeah yeah
gotcha but like that uh izzy guy now i
know his name because i've seen him so
many times yeah it's izzy right yeah you
should just call him [ __ ] zendaya
easy
yeah
what is it israel
yeah they call him israel which was we
saw him no no he wouldn't know this he's
not really told he's a 185 yeah good
looking dude yeah yeah he's a fan of
comedy he was at the laughing i saw him
a bunch but uh
that guy is just a menace but then like
so that guy was was doing really well
and then i knew he started know who he
was knowing who he was and then he was
like winning a lot and then i saw him
get his blue belt and i'm like this
guy's not even a [ __ ] blue belt he
just had such raw amazing kickboxer yeah
unbelievable like tall drink of water
lanky string bean dude and just [ __ ]
people up and has the confidence too
he's one of those guys that like wins
the fight before it even starts yeah i
like the gimmicky guys i'm such a
visible yeah like when brock lesnar was
fighting like i was rooting for him
every time i was like yeah that big
giant ape brock lesnar's gonna kill
everybody and then they had kimbo slice
for a while yeah i loved that i like any
kind of like big freak yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah where they go put him in there
he's never done this before and he still
does well because he's just a giant
fight i know that like the the the
lighter weight guys are like
you know a lot of them are like
technically better and like they can go
for longer rounds but like you're
learning chris yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah but but but but there's
there's something about the heavyweights
that it's just so much more exciting
because you know if they punch each
other they could die yeah you know so
god damn i am getting good dude you are
well like remember like in school like
if you just heard i was going to fight
somebody like jeff's fighting right
right right right but if you heard the
two biggest guys in school were gonna
rumble like everyone's gonna have one
job
yeah those are grown men are the biggest
ones but that's him that's that is he
dude that i was talking about you see
him before yeah uh he does look somewhat
familiar but it kind of looks like jazz
chisholm from the uh florida marlins
jazz chisholm you know that is does he
work does he do now uh he's like a
baseball player yeah that plays now he's
a real name is jism cool guy chisholm
yeah that was kind of silent but he kind
of looks like jazz chisholm
oh yeah he does oh right here for sure
he really does and he's tall and linky
and he's like really flashy definitely
here too yeah yeah good call good call
dude
i'm wondering if that's why i recognize
him well you can't even show the photos
uh we're working on it but we don't want
to because anything can get you taken
down it's a live stream oh yeah
gotcha
oh the mountain one huh jeepers i mean
that you gotta have so much power in
that punch huh wait the mountain from uh
game of thrones boxed a guy who do you
fight um
eddie hall oh my god they boxed
he beat eddie hall
the strong man well they're both strong
men you know the mountain is a cliff a
rainbow talking about just breeding the
headliner yeah
dude when he when you said you see that
clip of him fighting conor mcgregor yeah
that's what's up who's so slow the
mountain oh he's so slow well he's just
a big yeah he's an actor right i mean
yeah well no he's a strong one no yeah
he was the world's strongest man and
then did game of thrones those guys just
throw refrigerators on to like you know
bookshelves or whatever so crazy
they go ahead this is insane though
they don't need to have quick feet for
that
so this guy uh not dan hooker but the
guy he's fighting arnold allen his
brother and dad are strong men in
england
well factory guys i like the name hooker
nobody just forgot
last name hooker it's like that old
game's the hangman tj hooker yeah well
that makes me like it less
but it was 70s [ __ ] you know 80 [ __ ] so
that's cool
god shatner dude what up what i'm
chatting about yeah what a career that
that guy has had yeah like he's still
doing it i think honestly if you have a
career for a long time you're just
you're lucky anyway like you're just so
much [ __ ] could go wrong you picked the
wrong [ __ ] thing
you know you're out for like five ten
years but god that guy's the luckiest
[ __ ] dude you wanna hear shatness joy
i've never told you i'd love to hear it
getting a little trouble for this one
the uh
oh wait
he did the show with you right yeah he's
on the show so we spent all that time in
like tons of countries together
right better late than never on nbc i've
never seen it
your kids would love it it's actually
kind of a family it's fun it's funny
dude family friendly you would go it's
nbc yeah bradshaw
uh sherry bradshaw winkler henry winkler
and george foreman
so yeah that's the show so the uh so why
are you the only young guy i'm their guy
they needed some guy for for so people
would be like oh okay this is cool
george foreman looks like my grandma oh
they're all pretty old man yeah they uh
so like i represented like the viewer
you know they'd be like yeah like if you
were on vacation with them you'd kind of
view the traffic because they're always
taking bathroom breaks and i'd be like
right right the comedic kind of like
these guys the young guys schlep their
luggage around and stuff anyways so uh
backstage during the me too movement
right there's all this stuff all these
people are going down left and right
we're losing producers we're losing the
president of nbc's getting you know in
trouble yeah all this stuff's going down
and uh so we're all sitting there and
everybody's you know we're just being
boys in the industry going hey you got
anything to worry about and i said yeah
i don't think so yeah and then terry's
like ah no i don't think so you know i'm
kind of a loud flirty guy you know i'm
pretty old so who knows what could pop
up yeah yeah and then william shannon is
just sitting there just like
calm just like
cool as
can be here we go what about you bill
you worried about anything he turns and
he goes
anyone i've ever met is dead
i was like is that a murder joke
is that an age joke
you know like 50 minutes later you're
like you're in your truck going i don't
know what he meant
but he's always going for the joke he's
a funny it was hilarious um wait uh what
was going to say about that [ __ ] show
god damn it how how long was it on uh
two seasons yeah you enjoyed doing it
yeah it was fun season one we went to
asia forever and then season two we went
to europe africa and uh yeah went to
africa well just for one location damn
it wasn't it we were in uh
morocco jesus christ dude people say
africa like it's a country i do it too
all the time africa is a country that's
a big continent continent though yeah so
like egyptians are technically african
yeah yeah moroccans everybody's claiming
africa but it's up to you there's so
many different places
yeah but it's like i'm american but i
know no [ __ ] denver i know
no no that's different no but it's not a
continent the whole continent is north
america though i'm saying like oh i see
what you said yeah yeah
like if you met like like like like like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like like and subscribe egyptian i'm not
gonna say i'm from africa yeah you would
go on from africa you could you're just
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's still true but
it would just be silly to say that makes
sense yeah if i sound from north america
but like all right take it easy
just canadian yeah exactly canadian
you'll just be like it's such a weird
it's like when you're going from the bay
area i'm gonna start doing that me too
we're from north america
oh it sounds kind of cool yeah it sounds
exotic north america
no tattoos on these creeps either oh wow
that's this is a good fight usually this
is a great fight so
no tattoos dan hooker's coming down in
weight he usually fights at 55. he got
knocked out by michael chandler
um my guy your guy margaret
has got no ass
that guy has no apps yes
okay well that's why then he's got look
at it look at that he's kind of like you
at 145.
he's tall like he used to have an ass
but he had to like lose weight yeah 145
dude chin you got any tattoos uh take
your shirt off bub let's see you guys
chin has one chin i sold out like from
ireland dude i sold out like eight shows
in dublin i wanted to celebrate it and
so we all got the matching tattoos and
chin's crazy ass he has no tattoos and
you got that money's right here that's
loyalty i want it on my neck though he
wanted his neck when the tattoo artist
goes
what a weird country huh in america they
don't put it right on you they don't
give a [ __ ] yeah they probably put in
your [ __ ] america won't do it they'll
put it on your eye the white of your
eyes
he brought us money you did shows in
ireland yeah i did tour in uh uh england
and ireland went over to ireland i
remember you went over there i was like
you did eight shows in ireland dude i
did a show about two in the afternoon
and they were all in i didn't i did
three shows a day i did if you went to
ireland
yeah yeah i don't know and they speak
english yeah they do what that's what i
like it was the first like london
because i got all these countries
it didn't feel like it just felt like
america australia felt like america
dublin felt like i was in another
country wow like we went to a bar at
night where they had like a civil war
there and there's like bullet holes in
the [ __ ] walls and stuff
i mean i was dude i was pulling my own
guinness what size venue were you
playing
what's called the sugar it was called
the sugar hall it was like a small
theater it's cool yeah they don't have
clubs there right yeah
probably just they probably do actually
but you'd probably not i don't know if
they're too big for it probably like a
local thing i don't know though i don't
know then i did then i went to australia
i've never been there i i did all like
pretty big boy theaters england i did
all the big boy theaters i did though
too really yeah yeah be cool man huh
no because i don't think i would do i
wasn't i don't know if i would do them
or not you're bigger than me for sure
yeah i know i but i don't know a little
more international now but yeah well
especially with this [ __ ] like you yeah
but but i don't know if that was a joke
that was a joke
definitely more well-known yeah oh i
don't know i don't have a famous in me
you're more famous i
actually more like
they're like they're more loose
god oh he's rifling his dad's a strong
oh [ __ ] rose
oh my god oh this one oh my god not
getting out of the [ __ ] first round
holy [ __ ] oh [ __ ] toast they're gonna
get tired though but that was so long
for that oh my god oh he's already
wobbling
yeah yeah hooker's kind of where i'm
from you're not allowed to hit hookers
like that
don't say that
that was wild man that was scary boy
that was insane that was jim did i not
stay on the shop show this fight of the
night you did thank you sir you're
welcome yeah you really know your [ __ ]
huh you really break down your [ __ ] chin
knows a lot too the fact that you can
talk about that [ __ ] for an hour is
crazy ranting the camera for an hour you
know how it is yeah i do that but i'm
talking about like the biggest [ __ ]
silly hardest-hitting issues but
you're talking about only fighting which
is crazy but it's fun right you like it
my podcast i love doing it but he likes
talking about this yeah yeah it's a fair
affair you like it right fair
fair
yeah
no i do for sure yeah yeah i guess
that's a good point if you like it i
like being silly though but so in
fighting it's tough you know that's why
i love this show yeah this is my
favorite show to do
yeah when i did uh when i did that
chiang smith stuff oh [ __ ] gosh he
punches oh [ __ ]
he is lighting his boy this is
aggressive dude that arnold allen he's
won nine in a row by the way
holy [ __ ] that was a fun fight that kids
dude this card is [ __ ] guys
i told you you won 10 in a row now
that's 10 in a
a big boy next because dan hook was
pretty ranked he's pretty ranked high
yeah i've heard of him i've never seen
speed like that the whole day
so he was talking about how he grew up
and his dad was in strongmen his dad he
grew up with his dad injecting steroids
dude yeah into his
and he injected his dad no no his dad he
would walk in his dad be injecting
steroids into his own ass yeah and
arnold be like dad what are you doing
his dad's like do not do this [ __ ]
yeah like this is not this is how i
drink yeah yeah yeah
he's trying to lie to him no this is how
these are vitamins yeah i need more
sugar yeah he [ __ ] him up dan got one
good hooker got one good shot and now
there was one point that was he wobbled
him too
i'm telling you get a [ __ ] kid from
london on these [ __ ] cards and if i
know two arena they just have a [ __ ]
magic about a man that's why this card i
don't know why i didn't get more hype
next do you guys want to make a soccer
sucks joke just remember this right here
yeah exactly one of these [ __ ] might
be ball but it would be football though
you start making some dumb joke uh your
little soccer sport oh no no no
bro you see those you see a soccer
player's legs
they're like horse legs bro i want legs
like that not all of them though yeah
well i guess uh cristiano ronaldo has
those they have just they're just
fantastic juice they're juicing women
would kill for those yeah or you i'm not
a big leg guy oh i am i dated two chicks
without legs
wheelchairs
[Laughter]
hot in the face
[Laughter]
good with their hands hot in the face
i'm not a big lead guy at all
i like legs dude's got a good legs man
i'm all in like just being friends and
stuff really just being friends
or how do i repost some of the stuff you
guys are posting here
how do i do it oh do you are you heavy
on your social media game
me no i'm terrible you don't do it well
i do it yeah that's why it's terrible i
notice you don't follow anyone my
friends are like hey you haven't
done anything on instagram for a week i
was like yeah i was peeing out of my
butt all week right right but wait you
don't follow anyone because you're just
like [ __ ] it i don't want to have to do
that game yeah i don't like doing that i
get it yeah
do you have a podcast jeff you don't
even do it yeah friendship podcast jeff
dyson culture friendship yup
when's the last time you recorded one we
did one this week and i puked during the
middle of it
my friends because they we do it every
week and my friends were like we're here
and like oh god who's on it i put on
like a hat and i went downstairs i let
him in my house went upstairs where we
record oh god and uh i go i might have
to go to the hospital they're like what
what's wrong with you why do you smell
like i just smelled terrible and then uh
halfway through the pockets just puked
yeah wait who's on it you and who it's
just me and my producer uh nick greco
and then we have a guest each week okay
let me just hit kick it thank you i've
seen your i've seen the clips i haven't
seen it you won't hear a funny thing two
years ago i invited brendan schaub to be
on it and he responded on twitter he
goes yeah man no problem let's just
figure out a time so then i go
okay that's pretty cool that was easy
well he's like a famous guy this would
be great
we'll hit it off be buds you know and
then i kept
sending like uh what i kept but a few
times hey what about next week nothing i
said what about oh you know two weeks
from now i come back from the road
nothing and then uh when i first meet
him like last month i was like i think
we talked on twitter four times because
i don't do my twitter i was like oh
that's all i'm talking to some random
guy or girl
thinking i'm chopping up with brendan
shaw that's funny no and the [ __ ]
agreed to do the podcast that's that's
great that's great
what if i'm like let's go get drinks
you're like yeah meet me there it is
he's not even there
but meatball shows up i couldn't believe
that who the [ __ ] brendan i represent
him don't worry i'm his twitter guy
he drinks whiskey that's all right but i
was relieved because like it wasn't like
he was ignoring me he just never met me
then we hit him and i think i saw you
too one time and i was like that's weird
he acted like we didn't have that
correspondence yeah correspondence but
wait though he gets an [ __ ]
three months ago when you're like i
think i'm going to come hang you're like
i never met those you never met calling
your right hand yeah what you know
it's weird
and i'm like do you know jeff dyer's
like no we never i'm like yeah come like
yeah and that was great friends
instantly came my goddamn birthday party
i know that's for two days
[Applause]
my girl goes i don't want to talk about
it my girl goes i don't know if this is
sad or cool that you have a new friend
yeah i like it yeah
the girl's cool by the way yeah yeah one
thing i love the girl goes he's funny
i'm like yeah we think i hang out with
you yeah we're right here with some
people meet another [ __ ] good looking
guy around here
one thing i one thing i love is new
friends man just [ __ ] meeting new
people and and they're [ __ ] silly and
[ __ ] and i get new best friends i always
say i got my new best friend yeah me too
love it but it's also tough man it's
very tough yeah i'm a hashtag no new
friends no i know that i got triggered
during the show in nashville they end up
backstabbing you what's up
old friends even had a backseat with you
so what's up what's up
chris chris going through some [ __ ]
because what's up no friends for a
decade though and then there's
backstabbing so what were you saying
about the thing
about your uh your hashtag
a bit where he's like uh
he's like if you don't have kids once
you have kids if you if you're if you
have friends that don't have kids
that's it man i got you got nothing i
got nothing for you
in the audience just with a whiskey
watching us
i'm there with a bunch of [ __ ] dudes
going hey wait a minute i thought we
were new buddies
yeah you got to get a kid yeah did you
have wait you're 30 39 yeah yeah that's
when i had my first kid so yeah to this
is the year yeah at least you have a
lady we need to work that'll
yeah just find a lady and they'll knock
her up it's fine you know like
when colin farrell had his kid and i i
remember like uh i don't know him but i
would like read about it and he was like
yeah i met this girl and like she's cool
and like we're gonna have this kid but
like i don't you know he was like i
don't really know her but it's all good
man like we i don't really you know
we're gonna love we're gonna both love
the kid and it was like wow this is such
an interesting we had an agreement yeah
that we won't kill it so we're both yeah
do you do you want kids jeff yeah yeah i
don't need a bunch of kids my ideal
thing is to to meet a woman who has kids
already because i'm 39. yeah so now i
get to be that but then i do want one
you want one of your own right yeah yeah
i think it's the best it makes people
better
yes it does yes
i've known 20 guys in my life in the
last just in the last like few years who
who literally they're just they're just
better dudes my buddy tyler barker that
i keep referencing because he likes ufc
he's like the sweetest guy in the world
he's like the best i like i got teary
eyed last time i just remember like he
was sent me a photo of his new baby and
i was going man i would have killed for
a dad like him yeah like it's just like
to see like i don't know is it good do
you have a little girl or boyfriend i
think two girls i think having a kid
definitely not yeah
i think having a kid like in a way in a
way it can like bring out it just i
think it brings out who you really are
like you're you're going to be either a
good dad a good guy or you're going to
be a [ __ ] dead [ __ ] you're going to
know because you're going to know what
it looks like there's no middle right
yeah and my thing is if like if you're
and you know i have some friends around
my lives anymore once they had kids like
if you can be a shitty person to that
kid that you're flesh and blood i can't
trust you at all dude right if you're
gonna be a bad dad you're sure it's
[ __ ] like a ride for me when the [ __ ]
hits the floor you're like an easy
profile right like someone see you they
see jack that just uh there's you know
with the tattoos like the thing i would
look at that guy and go ah yeah that's a
scary guy you know i'm not gonna talk
[ __ ] to this guy then you look at his
instagram he's got his keys like
it shows the best part of people yeah
jordan peterson talks about that
sometimes he's like when he had first
had his uh son they would be pushing the
thing and you'd see like toughened kind
of like not gang members but like real
rough guys and then as the kid would go
by you know they would look at the
parents and then they would they'd see
like here and they do like little things
like it brings out the best in your head
a little kid or a dog or something it
brings the best out of people right it's
so weird too since i was a kid man i've
always wanted to be a dad always always
yeah i i just love i was never like that
i i didn't you know i would go mine was
always depending on like which
like who i was with like you know really
first marriage i was like yeah we'll
have kids and then i met a another girl
first marriage i didn't know yeah
i was 26 yeah yeah i didn't know that it
was young but and then and then the next
girl i was like nah we would just be
together no kids and then another girl
and maybe and then you know but then
when i met kristen i was like oh just
game on yeah yeah and my god man like
i mean i always talk about this on my
podcast but it's just like
i wish there was a way to even explain
it to people who didn't have kids but
they're just not
i've been serious for too long i'm gonna
pee out of my butt nice nice nice nice
yeah it's like the people that don't
like kids i'm like god you're missing
out man you are yeah i mean i didn't
know it i was i was kind of one of those
guys i was like just living life and i
was like on the road work was most
important
you know
but now it's just
i don't want to go it's also the people
that have kids and then they're not like
that into them like outside oh i don't i
don't get it man i mean to eat your own
you got to [ __ ] figure out your [ __ ]
but like
i don't i don't get it like i like
i woke up this morning and calvin was at
the park and like i'm like i didn't get
to see him and like i left to come here
and i was like this sucks i don't get to
see him for like okay
i don't get i don't know dude is that
how that's not how everybody feels
that's so weird to me like it's just
still ingrained in some weird disconnect
i guess i don't know
and then some people they grow up with
shitty parents i'm like oh i guess you
just don't have to run around much like
that's what i know yeah but you think
they'd be like oh that's not the way to
do it well some felt this way yeah some
people are like that but then some
people are just the opposite
like
you know you sometimes you meet two
brothers and it's like
one of them is just like their dad and
the other one's just like oh i didn't
want to be like my dad he's like oh they
just
experienced it differently
you gotta have more kids though yeah you
don't want to oh no yeah i'll have more
kids yeah no doubt and you have the
infrastructure your girl's mom's a beast
like that's part of him yup yup
this is the aspinal dude yeah he's a
stud man espinoza sounds so much like a
medicine
yeah really does yeah
he's a dad
he's a beast dad yeah how old are you i
ride with him 20 something 29 27 20 yeah
he might be 29 i know it's how the rest
of the [ __ ] world does it but it's so
crazy to me to like be in your 20s and
have like three kids dude i was talking
about girl about that the other day it'd
be i can't imagine how i can't imagine
it like i watched 16 and pregnant you
know how tough it is to be a [ __ ] dad
when i was 16 i'm pregnant i'm like dude
when i was 16 yeah
what
i had no life i like how did how am i
still alive little taking care of a
[ __ ] kid yeah i know like and then
the ju the routine and like yeah going
to bed at a certain time feeding them
waking up like not getting sleep being
16. yeah i was like you're trying my
[ __ ] history paper yeah taking care
of a [ __ ] baby well that's why
there's a lot of [ __ ] like it's like
the grandma raises them you know yeah
you're right
this show's fantastic he's 28. he's 28
yeah 20 kids 20 kids
man a hell of a card and oh i look at
that too
yeah it's it he it's a cover-up too oh
yeah something else but oh yeah he got
the moana tattoo remember grandma turns
into the big stingray
that's what he got on his back actually
i like to say that i don't think so he's
from russia so i don't think they watch
moana he's russian right chin yeah
yeah with that name and they were
worried about him getting out of russia
to come to the
england there's like three russian
fighters that there were yeah yeah i
heard peter yan's a little bit of
trouble too trying to get out because he
has a fight coming up
oh is corner men are stuck mike correct
jesus makes sense yeah because they're
allowing ukrainians into the states but
not
russians that's the sanctions
like poon doesn't give a [ __ ] about
coming to russia but effective you know
the rest of them it's insane dude
yeah they need aspirin all to win here
who's that
the ufc
oh really
volkov's been around he has shot at the
title
it doesn't do much for volkov to beat
aspinall for asphalt to be volkov it's a
big deal there's a story there's a
narrative
they haven't had a good heavyweight
fighter from [ __ ] england and i don't
know how long it's been a hot second
dude
he's like he's the first kind of like
real prospect of england who's ahead of
heavyweight
you have to be i mean there's no
americans have fought in this whole
thing is that not in england yeah that
won't they won't do that there's just so
much talent
overseas they don't need to do it
there's no maine guys my boy jack shore
won i heard his mic the night i heard it
was a great fight man that hooker he's a
tough fight but he has beat is this the
last one this is the last one yeah
yeah i haven't heard of this guy aspinal
yeah he's pretty brand new unless you're
balls deep in the game he's like the big
prospect out of england
he's got a confidence about him doesn't
he yeah he's a stud man he's been
dreaming of headline 02 since he was a
kid and here he is it's the first time
he's ever fought in front of a crowd
in the ufc because he's a covet baby
right so his first four fights in the
ufc there's no crowd because of
covington wow so his first big fight
arena
he's like he's it could be like he's new
we don't either yeah yeah you'd hope
better you never know go to arena's the
big arena in england i know that but why
is it called o2
uh i forget but though two sponsors
manchester united as well
is it uh telecommunications thing chen
let me see right now i think is it like
18 t out there
uh aspen all supposed to be looking he's
drinking happy hippo
that's been all supposed to be fun
drinking rain happy hippo you can tell
he's supposed to be a fat guy but he
works out so hard yeah you're right
telecommunications supposed to be a fat
guy you know what i mean he's like me
you know it's a real struggle get some
bad tats had to get him covered up there
oh that's exactly what happened
he goes uh just make it all black i
guess
seven fight win streak
he's only had one fight in ufc get out
of the first round and it ended early in
the second round
damn is that terry adam in the back
and darren till
they're in his corner yeah him and derek
is dude holy [ __ ]
in a long time and there's leon edwards
right there he's fighting kamar osman
and volkov always goes the distance
would you say volkov his opponent always
goes oh he's always
such a tough customer he's gonna be a
tough fight for the tower oh so he makes
it quick and the other guy goes this way
yeah yeah and he's
he's a world champion bellator yeah he's
fought he's beat for doom he's beat
[ __ ] over him ass balls like the new
young prospect so yeah no i know the
other such a jump up in competition yeah
in his hometown too first in front of a
crowd like there's so much pressure on
him he's a [ __ ] stud though man
you'll see how much more athletic he is
than the russian guy why he's got foot
tattoos so he's younger
yeah
yeah the other guy's been around i know
that i even know the other guys so
um
but foot tattoos are tough
they must [ __ ] hurt yeah
not for me dude no wow you don't have
any tattoos
if i got one i would be easy
you never want to get tattooed no no
there's really guys like that which is
amazing that wouldn't hurt me at all
yeah no i had when i was 17 i got a
tattoo of an armband you know like the
the barbed wire but i did it with thorns
and then i got a cross on it and then
literally like five months later i got
this huge chest thing that was like a
celtic knot
this is fantastic i don't know it was
pretty bad yeah yeah and then i was like
if i ever get money i'm getting these
things off my body i'm just gonna laser
these things off and so like the second
i got on last comic standing i had i
spent tons of money just getting more
hurts worse
way worse and it takes forever and it's
not a great process it's not even like
that
the technology's not that great it's
really hard to get a tattoo off so you
have to just keep going and keep going
yeah yeah this one took like
to get it off took
four years 22 treatments [ __ ] that 8 500
no no no no to get it on to 40 minutes
rock with it dude because it looked like
no that's not delay i gotta laser it off
let me see you can't see
you kind of see it like if you look
right there
why wouldn't you just have it yeah why
does it look like garbage no you look
like pamela anderson no dude
she has that same barbed wire that one
pretty
you don't want to get the ones that are
like cool with the time trendy yeah
trendy that's the problem yeah that yeah
you don't want to have like six months
of cool like you don't want a [ __ ]
stamp you know and also it's so bad that
people don't even believe it had six
months of cool yeah girls would go that
was never cool i promise you there were
six months where the girls were kind of
with those girls though was it cool the
the the barbed wire
yeah i remember working at red robin and
one of the hostess goes roll up your
arms so everyone could see your tattoo
and i was like yeah yeah jen payne wants
me to roll up my arm
and then like six months later i'm on a
boat i take my shirt off and everyone's
like what's with that white trash i was
like it was just cool wow that's funny
i had six months of dude i remember when
i was a kid i slapped close
six months i slapped the red robin
mascot you're kidding me i slapped the
mask out in his beak [ __ ] turned up
oh my god dad was so upset my brother
dared me to slap the mascot so i [ __ ]
after i got my steak fries he came by
he's like and i went swap
and his [ __ ] beak went right how old
were you 12 maybe you know what's funny
about that my dad made me my dad was so
pissed bro i imagine you shouldn't do
that
my dad goes do you know how hard that
guy has to work to make [ __ ] six
dollars an hour because we're going to
apologize to him and it made it worse
because we go in the back i can tell you
at the back of the kitchen here's the
mask off and he's just like [ __ ] kids
man yeah yeah and i'm like hey i'm sorry
man he's like it's fine dude happens
every just yeah he just ruined his day
like i felt so bad i thought you're
going a different way there because when
i worked at red robin the only people
that wore the mascot costume uh they
didn't get any extra money they got
jacked with all the time with the other
with kids and [ __ ] like that but then
also it's always a girl because no none
of the guys fit in that costume oh no
this was like a 45 year old man oh
really it must have been clearly a meth
addict yeah a little guy is a bad idea
oh man you guys are making me feel like
really bad right now look at volkov that
looks like a guy who fights just for
bread yeah yeah yeah look at that guy
yeah he's pretty rushed buffers into it
dude
is buffer balling oh see he looks tan
and better life that picture was brutal
he lives in malibu yeah he's balling
surfs every day
i heard he's very forgetful that guy
buffer buffer no he's good
very good very good at what memorizing
oh yeah no he's great at his job
such tough tough fight for hospital
uh
yeah still get nervous for these it's
kind of good do you oh yeah
really i feel the pressure for [ __ ] yeah
it's just ptsd i've been there man yeah
that guy's gotta win look at the size of
the three
nah he's good you he looks like a guy
who wins yeah
but this guy is young though yeah that
guy's been fighting cool he's a baby
yes just tattoo
gladiator
buffer's making a meal of it any
oh the main event buffer goes nuts you
know buffer blew out his knee
uh hosting a spring break party in las
vegas he's doing the bruce buffer like
360 move that he does and he was at a
pool at the [ __ ] venetian or whatever
and was like it's time and jumped in his
[ __ ] swim trunks slipped and blew out
his [ __ ] knee
i would pay any money to see that video
dude i stopped lifting i stopped lifting
when i first came to l.a i was lifting
at gold's gym in venice but bruce was
always there and when i'd walk in my
nickname in the ufc was big brown on the
hybrid
you know you just want to get your work
done i'd walk in and go
brendan the hybrid i'm like bro working
for free yeah that's really please don't
do it oh that no that's a guy i want to
hang out with yeah that should be like a
geico commercial like you're going to
get food yeah yeah yeah
the hybrid
dude i'm just trying to enjoy
my new my new best friend no he's great
you would love him oh dude he's so fun
six seven dude
oh now he's an underdog he started off
as the favorite he was minus one fifteen
now he's just gonna hungry to fight he's
russian dude that's my point his
quarterback couldn't be more russian get
him he just won't take his eyes off of
him
so when you go to the zoo and they just
start staring at you damn
you think ufc had given him a mic and
slim rant about the [ __ ] war in
russia in ukraine well at least they're
letting them fight i know everybody was
taking everybody off to everything yeah
look at the microphone with the dude
that's [ __ ] hilarious uh bruce has to
reach around holy funny
super gay
all right let's go dick to your [ __ ]
butt let's go here we go get the
microphone is anybody rooting for the
russian here and i like vocal i am i
picked them
yeah i picked them too because his name
yeah
he's listening
oh he's a big boy they're both big boys
i just think it's bigger but i don't
ever vote against a guy that's called
volkov you're saying who's bigger uh
well [ __ ] that's what i'm saying looks
like he's got something
six five yes but look at that
six seven
oh that was nice asmr is so much quicker
daddy that's gonna knock him out anybody
want to bet nothing he wants to bet i
don't know enough anybody want to bet
back there call brian he'll bet you know
way too much about fighting from the
beginning i'm off i didn't think yes
bond would have this much of a speed
advantage just watch it that's going to
knock him out
this ain't going out of the uh doesn't
go past three i would say it gets around
the first though
you can really tell that that dude on
the right really can fight forever
though
can you oh
can you imagine i swallowed a lock belt
as well on the ground oh he is he's a
black belt yeah he's known for stamp
because he's been starching everybody
but his grappling is really good wow
yeah
and and volkov's tough to take down too
man what's the name of that mask he's
got tattooed on his back
is it a geisha mask no no it looks
japanese
there's a name for those warrior things
it's on that movie three thousand
three hundred
three
three hundred three thousand that's the
news that's the secret sequel there's
tons of them now
three thousand what was it called the
name of that mask
it's where you didn't get something
russian though right
is it if it is that's not what the word
i thought it was
that's why it has like that cheetah
print that's pretty much
no no that's not lit brendan whatever
that thing i take it no no samurai a
samurai helmet
fundamentally based on the confrontation
between life and death
that's so russian you know sometimes uh
not subzero scorpion where is it yeah
hey you wanna bring up the scarce tattoo
and the history of mma bring up fedor's
brother
now fedor's brother fedor is uh
considered by some not me but considered
by someone
he's i'm telling he's gonna beat him oh
he's going for a camaro here
if he can trap that leg it's against the
cage and can't escape that's pretty lit
look at the bruise on his left leg jesus
wait that's from a kick right
oh good neither dude he's beating his sh
the [ __ ] out of him yeah yes oh she
swung his hands down he's smiling dude
that's russian it's russian mind games
bro so there's fedor's brother so
fader's brother was in the uh the dark
arts
he would say in the mafia and uh
that is a grim reaper with a baby
holding a knife yeah oh my god and the
baby looks strangely old yes oh my god
the baby looks like vern troyer it's
very strange have you seen that movie
the passion of the christ
the ceo
you've seen it right yeah yeah when the
when they're walking with it they reveal
the baby and it's like that white old
yeah it looks like that strange yeah
my grandma cried for three hours during
that movie and i ate raisinets it was
pretty she doesn't like raising this
watch because you're so used to mayhem
oh [ __ ] she took me when i was nice i
want to find that scene
we're not seen but like with the one i'm
referencing the passion of the christ
baby in the arms type in passion of
christ baby children oh this is the mask
that's what i was saying
and those guys would throw like it does
look like that where they throw like the
magic
another take down asparagus past this
with flying colors
nobody wants to build anything
oh i think he's gonna win that meatball
you're awfully quiet
there it is oh my god yeah it is so like
he was the holy [ __ ] the reveal is that
he's like this evil
second down row like it's like a baby in
this woman's arms but then when the baby
turns it's that what is it what is that
it's like symbolism
oh oh oh he tapped him wow now the first
round with what dude arm your guy elbow
respect flying [ __ ] colors it was a
commercial you basically arm like he
straightened it good for him look at
this that's the number six heavyweight
in the world he demolished him
you're telling me you don't see asthma
versailles gondow all right honest
question do you think like a regular
woman could beat him up
just trying to keep it fair
trying to be what i like about you man
you really do keep it fair i kept it 50
50. that question that's the ugliest
baby in the world by the way that was
what that's the ugliest what was this oh
yeah it wasn't about christ yeah but it
was like a symbol
what's the part though why is it like do
it why is that happening in the movie
yeah it's like satan right yeah it's
like the idea that like it's evil like i
don't know i don't know much stuff
but just remember that scene stuck out
to me it looks like that dude's tattoo
yeah dude is a it was you know yes i got
a wrestler
known as a bad dude he did some prison
time oh yeah i don't know if he's
probably fighting in ukraine right now
you know
wow he wasn't [ __ ] legit huh yeah
he's a real deal man past the this is
his first like real test and he passed
with flying [ __ ] yeah and also man
look at the marks on his side from some
of those kicks that dude that's like
he's bruised all in his that slip to the
takedown was fantastic i don't even know
you could bruise on the side of your
body it's like a camaro then you go
straight arm with it
boom about to snap oh damn it's very
frank mirror of him
oh [ __ ]
very frank mayor now he looks like frank
man he does a little
very frank marish
when you're right you're right dude to
beat volkov like that in the first round
dude we're going sizzler baby
wow
that's huge hey chin get that baby face
off that thing huh
that baby's [ __ ] staring at us yeah
it's good baby it's terrifying imagine
being that actor you gotta have a lady
hold you
well that's clearly not a baby that's a
force that's what i'm saying like that
actress oh god i'm doing the baby thing
again
i have to be naked and clean she's like
look at this face like nah it's perfect
for this oh here they go they gotta
stand by each other
wow what a moment for aspinal yeah
that's cool yeah pretty cool
father of three man
what do you think of this theory right
here this is not a theory but idea i've
got
you know like sometimes people just take
money to fight mm-hmm yeah yeah like
mike tyson before rojo's junior
everyone's like and they're both like
half dogging it you know
you both would get like
nothing right whatever you make from
your sponsors whatever you know you
don't get any money right unless you win
yeah the winner they do now that is what
they do so like when i was fighting like
say i fought tom tom aspen on i lost i'd
get half my pay i don't get my full
paycheck if i beat him you shouldn't get
any pay unless you win or take off wow
because you're gonna get money from
sponsors stuff they love you i mean not
really not a lot i mean at the time i
was but a lot of guys don't a lot of
guys don't no especially now because you
can't have sponsors
you got to be sponsored by benham uh
which you should be reebok back in the
day
what about brock lesnar's always wearing
jimmy john's around and all that i mean
five years ago dude i know
but now they made it so you can't have
any sponsors inside the room i don't
know
the octon looks like nascar but the
fighters have to wear venom uh shorts
why is that
because the ufc signed an exclusive deal
with venom or reebok and then that they
paid the ufc pays you so depending how
many fights you have you get a certain
amount of money it really [ __ ] the
fighters for the most part oh wow but
also made the it made the ufc more
professional
oh that's a great fight and taitu avasta
is looking to fight stipe but i think
it's going to be stipe john jones tom
aspinall versus tai tuvasa that's a
great fight for tom it's a great call
out too i think tai two of us is number
three in the world that's such a smart
move by uh tom
you think tom lose a tie oh you're
crazier and i love ty but that's a tough
fight for ty
you don't think he takes him down does
his wife
i think i like it
i would imagine nope
side chick for sure it's his manager
she's a big lady oh she's oh no oh she
has heels oh man he said don't kiss her
yeah
wow what a win do you think maybe that's
his sister or something what was that
that's his wife for sure
maybe that was her dad that she kissed
like that
why would she go kiss that guy no i was
a cheat kiss you kiss your kid on the
lips
yeah yeah me too
yeah that's the only thing i was real
passionate about like when i defended
tom brady people always like made fun of
that fact
i know i was like dude no no no like dad
sweetest he's like a redneck dad but in
general kids are like i bet reddick kids
get it they're like yeah i love my son
uh maybe
yeah that was weird that was a big
uproar yeah i was done he was like
getting a massage and kid was leaving
he's like he kissed him on lips when he
made a joke it was very playful he was
like he like needed money or something
he goes where are you going he's got
movies and he goes he's like uh all
right who's your favorite quarterback
because he knew they were recording yeah
yeah so he was like who's your favorite
quarterback and his kid being funny was
like peyton manning
it was funny it was like a very funny
not too old yeah and she goes all right
kiss me goodbye and then he goes
you know and he goes i'm your dad man
you're not getting too old like kiss me
yeah so like he made it it was like a
sincere moment and then tom brady and
his kid yeah it was like they did like a
facebook so he did he just and he just
went like this
he made him like keep his lips on his
lips like as a goof like you're never
gonna get too old for your dad and
parents were like cute it was like the
public was like pissed like the tattoo
show was like it was a little creepy
wasn't it it was a little creepy he's
like dude you're dumb
he didn't kiss his friend dumbass like
that he kissed his son like that
well this guy must be on cloud nine oh
my god god he's stuck also to to get
through a fight and not get knocked
around that much dude he got you he
and i'm not religious at all i'd get
behind the curtains of the arena and i'd
get on my hands and knees and be like
thank you whoever's up there i'm not
hurt man thank you so much
you're such a beast when you get hurt
yeah it sucks dude because it's like the
difference between like a shitty next
two weeks or not right like
awful or sometimes long you know you get
a real [ __ ] injury oh dude did you
see him walking down the tunnel he was
walking in the tunnel after that fight
and that meatwad chick was still like
doing it yeah she was twerking
she was popping her [ __ ] and everything
it was wild she's still dancing
she couldn't believe she can't get
enough stuff
should definitely get a [ __ ]
performance bonus i bet she should get
something who's rc uh
he is ryan clark what does he do he
played uh for the pittsburgh steelers
for a long time he's a big ufc fan it's
a little dicey you know what it is
that's like fight campaign ryan clark
doesn't know [ __ ] about mma but he's
doing a show with a mma yeah yeah
um dc is great though i love dc you love
him chris so dude he's great oh yeah he
loves football he's like a guy's guy a
great guy he's nice great guys he came
off a little a little strong when i'd
see him in interviews dc he's a great
opinion well that's the thing there's
like a spectrum for you guys your
fighters where it's like
how much is too much and how much is
just like a boring fighter you know
because not everyone's clever everybody
wants to be the only thing with [ __ ]
i don't know if you guys like like
russell wilson it's like is that his
name yeah yeah like just you don't have
to have a personality if you don't have
a personality if you're as good as he is
at football you don't have to what i'm
saying like muhammad ali you move more
product you get more stitch time if you
got some flash right but patrick mahomes
like doesn't say much he's just a
quarterback balls out right right but
i'm saying like in fighting like
muhammad ali started this thing where
you gotta like kind of whatever and not
everyone's that good at it
was amazing yeah so it's like with
cormier like i remember hearing him
talking going i don't know if this is
yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah he's a big
wwe fan and stuff but then like that you
play the long game like uh dustin
poirier right yeah like he doesn't talk
any [ __ ] but he doesn't but then like
over time
you get to kind of know him
and like just through what he's doing
and you're like oh i like this guy you
know what i mean dustin's a great guy
but but like you don't know that for a
while because he just doesn't say much
you know he's not only watching your
personality
but that's where conor changed the game
because
for better or worse like he came along
and he's like saying i'm a knock scout
in the first round he does it and he's
like so like animated and talking all
the [ __ ] and then makes so much money
fighters like i want money right that's
what we got to do all right and so it
was in their nature to do it but people
wanted to make like be a high profile
fighter so they started thinking i'm
gonna do what connor does but didn't
come off natural or organic yeah and
they just don't have the gift of the gab
so it got real cheesy for a hot second
there yeah this guy
i was wrong about hooker i gotta
apologize man like this chest punch
right not that one it's right before
that
his whole body collapsed i was rooting
for tom asman all but i said it was
gonna be tough i think i went two for
three if you count my tough i was i want
tom to win but i i said it was gonna be
tough and he [ __ ] steamrolled through
volkov dude that guy's gonna destroy his
girlfriend later no you're three for
three i mean kind of hey does paul
felder on the left not look like stephen
king a young stephen king he does
that's funny he looks like one of the
ghoulies
the bald gooey that comes out of the
toilet
old school reference i hope that guy
doesn't hear that me say that but yeah
he's a savage
great analyst
he retired yeah he was a really good
fighter at 55 but a really good analyst
i like god the ghoulies is so old-school
that's the he looks like a goose [ __ ]
and they pop out i put a red beard on
that bald ghoulie
that's what he hope he sees you invite
you no i don't want any trouble
but i like that chris goes was he a
fighter look at his face of course he
was using his nose yeah i didn't it he
looked like a handsome dude i don't know
he looked like he was a handsome dude
looks like stephen king you know you
look like a handsome steven king no but
i mean i know stephen king doesn't
remember writing most of his stuff
because you're so drunk wow well he the
only movie ever directed have you seen
that movie which one maximum overdrive
no it's so terrible that it's amazing
but he goes he apologized for it he goes
yeah i was on tons of drugs i don't even
remember being on set like the shining
he was like they asked him about it he's
like honestly i don't remember i was so
drunk
brendan is so funny he goes he looks
like a handsome stephen king and they
put stephen king up who looks like a
goddamn monster i don't think he looks
like stephen how could you be a hand am
i off on that there's something like
they have a similar mouth or eyes or
something
from the nose yeah i have a weird thing
where my the face recognition i can
always pick up on it's probably because
they both write such fantastic novels
[Laughter]
horror novels stephen king looks like a
googly too man yeah well there you go
you know he looks like a [ __ ] uh
sneetch remember those sneetches those
dr seuss
speeches on sneed videos
have you started watching that with your
kid what any of the dr seuss movies
they're fantastic well we watch the
grinch but
what's he into right now uh dinosaurs
yeah every kid loves a [ __ ] dinosaur
who wouldn't my kid goes dad are you
stronger than a
t-rex absolutely not
always doing are you stronger than this
and most time like yes yes yes
but every question you said t-rex right
absolutely not yeah but also he should
have known that well how are you
[ __ ] what are you doing yeah come on
correct and i don't use the hardware
very much my son says uh crush a tank
what do you
my son says uh what do you got you i
said what's your favorite dinosaur and
he says
tx
and i was like oh cool what about
triceratops i thought you liked that
he's your favorite and he says yeah
and i'm like oh you gotta make me
[ __ ] mine guys doesn't know what
favorites are yet yeah
doesn't it favorite the triceratops is a
vegan
chef tops oh yeah no it's a vegetarian i
told my son vegan i went you know he's
vegan right
yeah
he goes i like the brontosaurus oh you
know it's vegan though yeah yeah but he
hated cheese cheese they don't eat
cheese put cheese in front of his face
cheddar cheese he would bruh yeah i
would make him i would who wouldn't he
prove it hey prove it if cheese existed
back then they'd all eat it yeah yeah
yeah yeah [ __ ] off because you don't get
a hundred percent vegans until now maybe
they she leaves well that's it right
they're done that's it man that's
phoenix april 30. i'll be there
and i'm in chicago this thursday friday
saturday chicago schaumburg improv
chicago come [ __ ] get some the thick
boys are there and then after chicago i
am in phoenix arizona right before
crystalia april 14-16 stand up live
austin texas i'm headlining the moon
tower comedy festival april 22nd through
april 23rd it's just a friday and
saturday four shows at the new cap city
in austin texas we have special guests
in all of those cities come get some but
chicago you're [ __ ] up dude you guys
are up this week thursday friday
saturday sarasota florida come see jeff
dye go to crystallia.com
it's at mccurdy's then centralia
washington portland oregon bend oregon
look up those dates at jeffdye.com come
see me boy i wonder if this works dude
how many people are watching right now
chin
uh whatever it was like 5k watching live
so chrisleya.com i can see right now
there's four people on my website
phoenix chrisley.com let's see let's see
that number go i wonder if it works just
wondering right
dude celebrity theater is a big boy some
of those irvine ones i i gotta jump on
with you oh yeah there's more urban
decay
or christmas quit and shows though you
know do bigger venues yeah i didn't
really know yeah but now hey bigger
venues though no no no no no no but i
was just working i was working [ __ ] out
and this phoenix one though that's going
to be the chris won't say this but uh
every show we do together so at brea san
diego chris is selling at least five
thousand tickets every market you've
never been bigger man i've never been
more proud of you thank you
i love you you're not gonna brag about
that but i will and don't push me that's
right thank you i love you hey there's
62 people on my website yeah there you
go that's a lost leah.com that is a lot
bigboy.com
and we're moving it up food bigboy.com
merch just dropped oh there's there's
your meat what'd you call it i love that
shirts off
see that's what i'm talking about the
guy who just finishes fighting doesn't
change at all yeah he looks like he
lives in a tree or something
like he has like a or like a big boot
that's got a window on it yeah yeah yeah
83. yeah
all right chicago yeah let's let's plug
his numbers more i got 12 people go see
jeffy if you're in florida go see jeff
oh jeff's a monster also three of us to
be at the hollywood improv this
wednesday
106. what the [ __ ] yeah welcome to the
power of thick dude
all right guys we love you shout out to
ufc london we're out love you meatwad
you